l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement
la première d'entre elles va être posée
par Monsieur Jérémy patrietus pour le
groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
dimanche dernier des centaines de
Français au visage agar et sidéré aux
yeux en bués et émus on marchait en
silence dans les rues de Dozulé dans le
Calvados départements dont vous êtes
comme moi l'élu nous avons marché en
silence pour rendre hommage à
l'orpeuillet une femme lumineuse et
rayonnante une maman de 28 ans
bibliothécaire passionnée par son métier
leur feuillet aimer la vie elle lui a
été arraché par son compagnon qui selon
toute vraisemblance la assassiné à
l'arme blanche le 14 février dernier
il y a un an l'or feuillet avait brisé
le silence et porter plainte contre son
compagnon pour violence conjugale cela
n'aura pas suffi
l'orfeuillet et le visage de toutes ces
femmes tombées sous les coups de leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint les chiffres
sont glaçants ils font froid dans le dos
28 femmes sont mortes assassinées depuis
janvier dernier encore deux le week-end
dernier c'est une femme tous les deux
jours et demi jour après jour le
décompte macabe se poursuit et le même
bilan glaçant se répète qui décrit des
vies et des familles brisées à ce
chiffre épouvantable nous pourrions
ajouter les centaines de milliers de
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
madame la Première ministre la
République doit protéger l'ensemble de
ses filles et mettre fin à ce fléau qui
pourrit notre société et traverse tous
les milieux sociaux si depuis plusieurs
années des mesures ont été prises dans
le prolongement notamment du Grenelle
des violences conjugales force est de
constater que des failles et des
dysfonctionnements majeurs persistent
madame la Première ministre je connais
votre engagement et votre détermination
à lutter contre les féminicides il y a
urgence à agir nous le devons alors
feuiller à toutes ces femmes assassinées
ma question est simple quel plan
national d'urgence pouvez-vous mettre en
place pour enrayer ce fléau et dire aux
femmes qui nous écoutent en cette veille
de la Journée internationale du droit
des femmes que dans notre pays en France
la République les protégera toujours des
coûts de leur conjoint de la folie de
leur prédateurs je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame Isabelle Rome
ministre délégué chargé de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes de la
diversité de l'égalité des chances
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
député patriaretus vous m'a interpellé
sur le drame qui s'est produit à Lisieux
le 14 février
permettez-moi tout d'abord d'avoir une
pensée pour l'or la victime vous le
savez pour la deuxième fois le président
de la République a fait de l'égalité
femme homme la grande cause du
quinquennat et ce combat contre les
violences intra familiales est un combat
de chaque instant sans relâche tant
qu'il y aura des coups et des
féminicides notre combat ne s'arrêtera
pas demain je présenterai aux côtés de
la première ministre un plan égalité
2027 qui comportera un certain nombre de
mesures ambitieuses pour la protection
de ces femmes la première ministre en a
déjà annoncé hier quelques-unes dont par
exemple une ordonnance de protection
immédiate qui permettra une mise en
sécurité très rapide de la victime de
même pour aider les victimes à
s'extraire des griffes de leur bourreau
parce que ce n'est pas facile de quitter
son conjoint quand il est violent et
bien la première ministre a annoncé la
mise en place d'un nouveau dispositif le
pack nouveau départ que j'ai pu lancer
la semaine dernière dans le Val-d'Oise
pour un premier territoire
d'expérimentation ce dispositif
permettra de bénéficier de de aux
victimes de bénéficier donc d'aide avec
un seul référent à l'Inter par
l'intermédiaire des cases allocations
familiales et sur différents aspects que
ce soit une allocation que ce soit en
termes d'accompagnement à l'emploi ou à
la formation que ce soit un
accompagnement psychologique un aide à
la une aide à la garde d'enfants ou
aussi un hébergement d'urgence si besoin
je précise que ce pack peut s'appliquer
aussi bien aux femmes qui quittent le
domicile qu'à celle qui reste et dans le
conjoint a été évincé
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
devons rester humble justement dans ce
combat et ne jamais faire de
triomphalisme et nous devons au
contraire
œuvrer au quotidien
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien taché
pour le groupe écologiste
chers collègues madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères le président de la
République est rentré dimanche à Paris
après une tournée de 4 jours en Afrique
centrale et c'est maintenant l'heure du
bilan au Gabon sous prétexte d'un sommet
sur la forêt boycoté par la société
civile et les ONG le président n'a fait
que renforcer Ali Bongo coeur battant de
la France Afrique à la veille d'une
élection présidentielle au Congo
Brazzaville il s'affiche tout sourire
avec Denis sasuenguesso président
militaire et responsable d'une guerre
civile ayant entraîné le massacre de
milliers d'opposants il passera ensuite
en Angola sans dire un mot de l'immonde
projeté comme de Total énergie qui a
déjà conduit à l'expropriation de plus
de 100000 paysans puis pour clore cette
magnifique tournée il s'est rendu samedi
en République démocratique du Congo et
là ce fut le clou du spectacle incapable
de dénoncer le financement de la milice
M23 par le Rwanda le président à cru bon
d'insulter Félix ticket CDI puis c'est
embourbé dans un discours au volant
colonialiste qui a profondément choqué
son homologue et l'ensemble simple du
plus grand pays francophone au monde
finalement madame la ministre cette
tournée d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un peu
un mélange de Tintin au Congo et de ss17
en Afrique alors comment s'étonner
ensuite que l'influence russe s'étende
depuis des années sur le continent
africain ou le sentiment anti-français
lui ne fait que croître que beaucoup de
ces états refusent de s'engager à nos
côtés dans le soutien à l'Ukraine
qu'après notre échec en Libye puis au
sel de grands pays comme le Mali ou le
Burkina Faso nous demande de fermer nos
casernes militaires chers collègues
croyez-vous vraiment que ces états sont
aveugles à la différence de traitement
dans l'accueil des réfugiés venus
d'Ukraine face à ce venu d'Afrique ou du
Moyen-Orient ou encore ainsi que
l'acteur Omar Sy ou la récemment rappelé
qu'il ne voit pas notre indifférence
face au conflit qui ravage leur
continent la guerre oubliée du tigree
qui s'achève à peine a fait 600 000
morts en Éthiopie et Emmanuel Macron a
pourtant reçu habillé Ahmed responsable
de ces massacres en grande pompe à
l'Elysée le mois dernier il est temps
d'en finir avec ce double standard en
matière de droit humain et de démocratie
en Afrique l'Empire français s'est
terminé c'est maintenant avec les
diaspora la société civile et surtout la
jeunesse que de nouvelles coopérations
doivent se construire à égalité alors
madame la ministre vous qui êtes une
diplomate aguerrie ma question est
simple qu'avez-vous pensé de cette
tournée du professeur Macron en Afrique
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
le 27 février vous vous en souvenez le
président de la République a fixé le cap
de notre politique à l'égard de
l'Afrique un continent qui présente
d'immenses potentialités pour les
décennies et les décennies qui viennent
en un mot nous voulons y créer des
partenariats équilibrés dans le respect
réciproque et sans arrogance mais sans
complexe comme il l'a dit sans arrogance
parce que nous n'apposons ni de
solutions ni notre vision du monde car
nous avons des atouts à faire valoir nos
liens humains nos diaspora vous les avez
cités l'engagement de notre jeunesse nos
entreprises nos universités sans
complexe car nous avons une proximité
entretenir sans connivence ingérence et
en nous soutenant aucun candidat vous le
savez bien et en parlant avec tout le
monde y compris avec les oppositions
comme toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
journée de grève et de manifestations
depuis 50 ans alors où je vous parle
l'essentiel des trains des métros et des
bus ne circulent plus aucune goutte de
carburant ne sort des raffineries les
chaînes de l'industrie sont à l'arrêt
les centrales électriques réduisent
leurs production et d'ores et déjà des
assemblées générales ont décidé de
poursuivre 2 poursuivre la grève pour
demain mais vous faites la sourde
oreille vous ignorez vous méprisez vous
mentez vous misez sur le découragement
vous montrez du doigt ce à qui vous
n'avez pas laissé d'autres choix que la
grève vous tentez de dresser les
Français les uns contre les autres vous
faites du mal à un pays qui souffre déjà
beaucoup vous êtes irresponsable mais
vous n'y arriverez pas chaque jour qui
passe l'opposition à votre réforme
s'amplifie l'ensemble des syndicats ont
appelé au blocage du pays deux tiers des
Français les soutiennent dans cette
démarche les caisses de grève
remplissent le peuple est solidaire de
ceux qui sacrifient des journées de
salaire pour défendre l'intérêt général
nous leur apportons notre soutien total
madame la Première ministre vous ne
pouvez pas gouverner seul contre tout le
monde il n'y a pas de 49-3 contre
l'Union Populaire il n'y a pas d'autres
à reculer d'autres l'ont fait avant vous
en 1995 il aura fallu trois semaines de
grève pour l'abandon du plan Juppé en
2006 un mois de manifestation aura
permis la fin du contrat première
embauche madame la Première ministre
convient de temps allez-vous faire payer
au pays le prix de votre enquêtement
quand allez-vous enfin retirez votre
texte de loi merci beaucoup la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre
du Travail de l'insertion et du plein
emploi
merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Bompard
votre question par son ton comme par son
fond et symptomatique de votre
positionnement politique
symptomatique parce que vous appelez au
blocage vous appelez pour reprendre
l'expression d'un responsable syndical à
mettre l'économie à genoux mais mettre
l'économie à genoux c'est mettre les
travailleurs à genoux c'est mettre les
cases à genoux c'est mettre en
difficulté les petites entreprises c'est
mettre en difficulté les plus fragiles
dans notre société votre question elle
est aussi symptomatique parce que d'un
mot vous dites vous êtes seul la
première ministre n'est pas seule la
première ministre est accompagnée par
toute la majorité et elle est aussi
accompagnée au-delà de la majorité par
toutes celles et ceux qui en
responsabilités savent que ce que nous
faisons permet la pérennité du système
par répartition et permet de garantir la
solidarité intergénérationnelle et puis
enfin Monsieur le Député votre question
est symptomatique pour une troisième
raison vous faites le choix de
l'outrance vous faites le choix des
grandes déclarations vous faites le
choix du blocage et en réalité vous
répétez le choix de l'obstruction nous
avons fait le choix du débat et de la
discussion vous avez fait le choix de
l'Ob struction vous avez fait le choix
de l'irresponsabilité et vous avez le
faire un choix qui est finalement
d'esquiver esquiver la responsabilité ne
pas regarder l'avenir ne pas faire face
aux enjeux notre majorité elle est
responsable pour vous
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Émilie Chandler
pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministres de la Justice 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes 19
novembre Journée mondiale pour la
prévention des habits envers les enfants
20 novembre journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant 25 novembre journée
internationale contre les violences
faites aux femmes quatre dates dans
notre calendrier qui sont une occasion
de plus pour rappeler les violences qui
sont présentes dans les familles ces
violences elle brise des familles mais
surtout des vies car au-delà des
chiffres de 200 8000 femmes victimes de
violences conjugales en 2021 des 159
femmes hommes et enfants décédées en
2021 dans un contexte de violence au
sein de la famille ce sont des gens qui
meurent
depuis le 28 septembre avec la sénatrice
Dominique Verrien nous travaillons dans
le cadre de la mission qui nous a été
confiée par madame la Première ministre
visant à améliorer le traitement
judiciaire des violences intrafamiliales
dans le cadre de cette mission nous
avons déjà rendu certaines
recommandations
ce que nous demande les victimes ce que
nous demande les associations ce que
demande les Français à commencer avec
une première avancée par le pack nouveau
départ annoncé par madame la Première
ministre à Isabelle Rome parmi les
recommandations que nous avons rendues
la mise en place des pôles spécialisés
dans les violences intrafamiliales dans
les tribunaux et l'instauration d'une
ordonnance de protection immédiate ont
été annoncées sur l'épaule au cours de
la mission j'ai pu constater que la
circularisation de l'information entre
le différents acteurs de la chaîne
judiciaire étant élément essentiel pour
lutter contre la violence au sein des
familles presque toutes les juridictions
développées leur modèle pour répondre à
la masse grandissante du contentieux il
est important d'aider nos concitoyens à
mieux s'y retrouver sur l'ordonnance de
protection immédiate que nous vous
avions proposé en tant qu'ordonnance
d'éviction de mise à l'abri l'annonce
faite semble entraîner beaucoup
d'interrogations sur son utilité sans
temporalité notamment de la part des
avocats pourriez-vous donc monsieur le
ministre nous apporter des précisions
sur les modalités de ces deux mesures
annoncées par madame la Première
ministre je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Émilie Chandler je sais à quel point
depuis le 28 septembre avec votre
collègue madame Verrien vous vous êtes
investi pour améliorer encore la réponse
que nous pouvons apporter à ces
terrifiants féminicides nous avons déjà
vous le savez beaucoup fait téléphone
grave danger bracelet anti rapprochement
ordonnance de protection déferments
condamnations beaucoup plus ferme mais
force est de constater que ça n'est pas
suffisant hier vous avez présenté un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
été reprises avec enthousiasme par
madame la Première ministre et que je
reprendrai également à mon compte avec
le même enthousiasme de quoi s'agit-il
des pôles spécialisées et non pas des
juridictions spécialisées je veux
rappeler que vous avez auditionné une
centaine de personnes
je veux rappeler oui je veux rappeler
que ces pôles ont d'ores et déjà été mis
en place après Mérignac 123 il faut
généraliser ses pôles à l'ensemble des
tribunaux judiciaires 164 et des cours
d'appel et puis la deuxième mesure qui
est importante c'est l'ordonnance de
protection elle était prise dans un
délai de 40 jours nous avons réduit à 6
jours il faut encore impérativement
réduire ce délai à 24 heures comme l'a
annoncé hier madame la Première ministre
nous allons trouver évidemment toutes
les solutions pour présenter le plus
rapidement possible un texte qui va dans
ce sens pour une raison toute simple
madame la députée c'est que c'est le bon
sens
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Tanguy pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre une hausse des prix de
l'alimentation de 25% en seulement 18
mois voilà la réalité terrible que
doivent affronter les Français quand les
salaires eux n'ont augmenté que de 4 à
6% sur la même période de moins en moins
entre mensonges grossiers et
incompétence crasse vous avez promis que
l'inflation était sous contrôle on voit
le résultat vous aviez promis des
mesures jamais vues des mesures fortes
on voit le résultat un pauvre logo un
énième slogan pour faire la publicité de
la grande distribution au frais du
contribuable vous aviez promis un
carburant proche de 1,50 €. il est
presque à 2 euros seuil que Total
accorde dans sa grande mansfitudes après
que vous l'ayez supplié de partager les
18 à 35 milliards d'euros de bénéfices
que vous avez sciemment protégé
en réalité madame la Première ministre
comment pourriez-vous combattre une
inflation dont vous chérissez en réalité
les causes la banque centrale a rendu
son verdict ce ne sont pas les hausses
de salaire qui nourrissent l'inflation
elles sont faméliques ce n'est pas
l'emballement de l'économie réelle elle
est au bord de l'effondrement non ce qui
nourrit aujourd'hui l'inflation ce sont
les surprofits indécent que font les
multinationales et c'est sur profit vous
les avez protégés
seul seul Marine Le Pen avait eu le
courage de le dire seul Marine Le Pen
avait eu le courage de le dire et de
proposer des mesures qui permettaient de
combattre les causes de l'inflation car
en réalité voilà votre bilan le travail
ne paie plus en France mais c'est le
travail des Français qui paie la
cupidité des multinationales vous avez
inventé leur ruissellement à l'envers
l'argent de nos gros patriotes sur tous
les territoires via arroser les
multinationales aussi ma question est
simple à la première ministre quand
allez-vous rendre leur argent en
français
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean-Philippe Tanguy
la justice fiscale c'est nous
l'incompétence fiscale c'est vous
la justice fiscale
c'est d'aller taxer
lance des énergéticiens pour récupérer
la rente qu'ils ont fait sur
l'électricité ou sur le gaz pour
apporter 46 milliards d'euros Trésor
public que vous n'avez pas voté la
justice fiscale
c'est la mise en place d'une imposition
minimale à l'imposition sur le revenu
poussé par cette majorité poussée par ce
gouvernement défendu et obtenu par le
Président de la République 15% de
taxation minimale c'est la justice
fiscale c'est vous qui l'avez obtenu
vous ne l'avez pas voté la justice
fiscale c'est axé les gens du numérique
les Google les Amazones les Facebook
tous ceux qui jusqu'à présent n'étaient
pas taxés et qui grâce à cette majorité
vont peut-être taxés pour 700 millions
d'euros de revenus fiscal en 2023 vous
l'avez voté vous ne l'avez pas voté
mesdames et messieurs les députés du
rassemblement national vous ne défendez
pas la justice fiscale vous défendez
toujours les mêmes idées vous n'avez
qu'un seul mot à la bouche la TVA La TVA
La TVA mais prenons vos solutions si
nous baissions la TVA sur les produits
alimentaires cela coûterait 7 milliards
d'euros si nous baissions la TVA sur
l'essence cela raconterait 10 milliards
d'euros 17 milliards d'euros a supposé
que ça n'aille pas dans la poche des
distributeurs ou des industriels c'est
toujours trois fois moins que les 46
milliards d'euros que nous nous avons
mis pour protéger les Français contre
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
et du gaz l'incompétence c'est vous la
décision la justice c'est nous
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur Tanguy
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre le maire comment
pourriez-vous taxer les surprofis def
puisque vous avez tellement envie de ces
entreprises qu'elle fait 18 milliards de
pertes
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Annie genevas pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
première minute nouvelle illustration du
en même temps cher au président de la
République notre pays a en effet réussi
la performance diplomatique d'être en
froid et avec l'Algérie et avec le Maroc
le Maroc a rappelé son ambassadeur à
Paris le 19 janvier dernier et dénoncer
ces derniers jours des relations avec la
France qui sont je le cite ni bonne ni
amical terrible constat de la part de ce
pays traditionnellement tamis le 8
février c'était au tour de l'Algérie de
rappeler son ambassadeur pour
consultation afin de protester contre
l'exfiltration de la militante
algérienne Amira Bouraoui dans la foulée
le pays annonçait qu'il cesserait de
délivrer les indispensables laissez
passer consulaire concrètement cela
signifie que l'Algérie ne reprend
désormais plus aucun de ces
ressortissants expulsés par la la
première ministre au-delà des
conséquences diplomatiques désastreuses
qui contribuent à faffaiblir toujours
plus notre pays déjà à la peine sur le
continent africain cette crise avec deux
pays majeurs du Maghreb révèlent une
fois de plus l'échec de votre politique
d'expulsion des étrangers en situation
irrégulière
0,2% avec l'Algérie et 2,4% avec le
Maroc comment madame la Première
ministre dans ces conditions
diplomatiques particulièrement
défavorable comptez-vous réaliser la
promesse de votre Ministre de
l'Intérieur d'atteindre 100% des auqtf
engagement qui apparaît de plus en plus
au mieux comme un vieux au pire comme
une promesse à laquelle personne de
sérieux ne peut accorder le moindre
crédit
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
madame la présidente madame la députée
la France est liée au Maroc à l'Algérie
par des liens d'une nature
exceptionnelle des liens qui dépassent
les personnes et qui dépassent les
contingences car ils prennent racine
dans une histoire partagée une histoire
d'une richesse mais aussi du complexité
vous l'avez dit qui est tordu comment
alors ces liens hors du commun on peut
les voir à l'oeuvre avant tout dans les
échanges humains nos trois pays sont
liés indéfectiblement par leur jeunesse
par leurs étudiants par leur langue par
leur histoire par les histoires
familiales des histoires imbriquées dans
la grande Histoire malheureusement
madame la députée dans ce genre de
relation étroite on ne peut éviter
parfois des périodes de doute ou
quelques accrocs on le sait mais ce qui
est important c'est ce que nous voulons
pour l'avenir par delà c'est
vicissitudes c'est le sens de la visite
d'amitié du président de la République
en Algérie fin août dernier et c'est
celle de madame la Première ministre en
octobre octobre oui qui ont l'une et
l'autre traçaient des perspectives pour
le temps long entre nos deux pays y
compris sur le plan mémorial et
d'ailleurs je voudrais ajouter qu'il ait
de la responsabilité de tous de
contribuer à développer notre relation
avec l'Algérie ce que nous voulons pour
l'avenir madame la députée c'est aussi
ce que j'ai présenté au Maroc en
décembre visite qui a posé un jalon
important et qui était nécessaire vous
le savez alors avec le Maroc comme avec
l'Algérie nous regardons vers l'avenir
car nous avons une ambition forte et
nous entendons poursuivre ce travail au
bénéfice de nos peuples et en
particulier au bénéfice de nos jeunesses
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la ministre merci beaucoup madame Jeanne
var
merci madame la Présidente alors ce
double fiasco madame la ministre
humanitaire pardon ce double fiasco
diplomatique et migratoire ne vous est
sans doute pas directement imputable
néanmoins les conséquences sont là et je
regarde monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur aujourd'hui plus aucune
occf ne peut être satisfaite notamment
avec l'Algérie comment allez-vous
répondre à ce problème majeur pour notre
vie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
najlaine pour le groupe yote merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre alors que certains parlent de
mettre la France à genoux je voulais
vous interpeller sur ces personnes qui
peu importe les crises ou les pandémies
sont au côté de nos concitoyens et
notamment des plus fragiles les
infirmières et les infirmiers libéraux
n'ont ni bénéficié de la prime covid ni
celle du Ségur de la santé ils sont des
maillons essentiels pour notre société
pour assurer la continuité des soins
dans un contexte où le gouvernement
affiche une politique ambitieuse du Bien
vieillir à domicile ils sont toujours en
première ligne exerce un métier pénible
dont la pénibilité n'est pas prise en
compte pour le retraite et Palli le
manque de soin sur nos territoires sous
dotés la revalorisation financière de
leurs actes est inchangé depuis plus de
10 ans alors que la France connaît un
contexte inflationniste préjudiciable à
tous
leurs indemnités forfaitaire de
déplacement est fixé à 2,50 €, ce qui
est à la base plus que minime ce qui
devient insignifiant au vu de
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence
d'autant plus que son montant d'autant
plus indécent contenu qu'au 31 décembre
2022 l'aide exceptionnelle au
déplacement pour ses professionnels qui
bénéficient depuis avril 2022 d'une
maigre revalorisation de 4 centimes a
été supprimée cette indemnité est
complétée par une indemnité kilométrique
de 50 centimes d'euros par kilomètre dès
lors que le patient n'habite pas dans le
village du professionnel ce qui crée une
fois de plus un préjudice pour nos
territoires ruraux je prends l'exemple
de cette infirmière Bressaude qui se
voit refuser ce remboursement pour seul
faute avec pour seul faute d'exercer
dans une commune de 57 km². madame la
Première ministre quand en faire le
gouvernement pour que d'une part on puis
nous puissions assouplir ces conditions
qui ne prennent pas en compte la réalité
de tous les territoires mais aussi
simplement pour envoyer un signal fort à
toutes ces femmes et ses hommes qui tous
les jours assurent une présence et un
service indispensable
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Christophe negelène vous avez
raison de le dire les infirmières et les
infirmiers libéraux sont essentiels pour
l'accès aux soins et à la santé de nos
concitoyens dans la France rurale dans
les zones de montagnes dans les petites
communes ou dans les villes moyennes ils
sont bien souvent les visages
accessibles du soin en semaine comme le
week-end il parcourt des dizaines de
kilomètres par jour au contact des
Françaises et des Français qui en ont
besoin au nom du gouvernement je veux
leur dire toute ma reconnaissance et
avec le ministre
et avec le ministre de la Santé François
Braun nous sommes mobilisés à leurs
côtés
concernant l'indemnité kilométrique nous
sommes bien conscients des difficultés
notamment dans ces périodes de prix
élevés des carburants dès 2019 le mode
de calcul des indemnités kilométriques a
été révisée pour mieux prendre en compte
la réalité des déplacements il y a
désormais plus de règles uniques dans
tout le pays et c'est à l'échelle de
chaque département qu'elles peuvent être
négociées en tenant compte des réalités
locales et en écho à votre alerte le
ministre de la Santé demandera à
l'Assurance Maladie de veiller à la
bonne prise en compte des réalités
locales de plus l'an dernier l'assurance
maladie a revalorisé les indemnités
kilométriques pour les infirmières et
infirmiers libéraux et bien sûr les
infirmières et infirmiers libéraux ont
bénéficié des différentes aides mises en
place par le gouvernement qui ont été
doublés par l'Assurance Maladie
s'agissant de la rémunération nous avons
mis en place en 2020 le bilan de soins
premier qui a rénové le mode de
facturation des actes infirmiers avec
une rémunération forfaitaire journalière
adapté aux patients et depuis le 1er
janvier 2022 cet outil a été étendu à
l'ensemble des patients dépendants et ce
bilan de soins infirmiers connaît un
succès important et nous allons
pratiquement doubler les financements
avec 217 millions d'euros d'ici 2024
pour autant je sais que des
interrogations des doutes et des
difficultés persistes c'est pourquoi
nous travaillons avec les soignants pour
faire évoluer le métier d'infirmier
libéral nous voulons notamment permettre
une adaptation des formations des
référentiels d'activités et des
compétences une mission commune des
inspections du ministère de la santé et
de l'enseignement supérieur est en cours
sur ce sujet et par ailleurs le
gouvernement se mobilise pour enrichir
ce métier d'infirmiers et d'infirmières
libéraux je pense à l'élargissement des
compétences vaccinales par exemple ou
encore à l'expérimentation de
l'établissement de cert jusqu'à deux
décès très attendu dans les territoires
notamment par les mers vous voyez
monsieur le Président néjlaine cette
évolution du métier d'infirmière et
d'infirmiers va de père avec le
renforcement de son attractivité qui est
l'une des conditions pour assurer une
meilleure offre de soins sur tous notre
territoire et je sais que cette
préoccupation est très largement
partagée sur ses bancs comment témoigne
l'adoption à la l'unanimité de la
proposition de loi portée par la
rapporteur général Stéphanie Rist ces
dernières semaines je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien Lainé
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire je souhaite
vous interpeller à propos de la
situation sanitaire au regard de
l'influence ça aviaire hautement
pathogène qui frappe durement nos
éleveurs et au-delà toute la filière
avicole pour faire face aux différentes
vagues depuis 2017 le gouvernement a
toujours été aux côtés des acteurs de la
filière pamilthead via des
indemnisations massives en tant que
parlementaire landais je souhaitais
saluer cet effort constant au printemps
2017 le ministre de l'Agriculture
d'alors avait signé un pacte de
biosécurité avec la filière palmite à
foie gras créant ainsi de des mesures
préventives et réglementaires cherchant
à réduire les risques de diffusion et de
transmission dans le sud-ouest de la
France entre le 15 décembre 2022 et le
15 janvier 2023 le gouvernement a mis en
place le plan Adour ayant pour but de
créer un vide sanitaire ce plan a permis
de limiter considérablement le nombre de
foyers d'épisotis permettant de relancer
le repeuplement des volailles malgré les
avancées conséquentes de la biosécurité
l'épisotis se répète ce généralise en
France et en Europe mais fort
heureusement nous en trouvons désormais
un espoir avec l'arrivée prochaine du
vaccin
sans qu'elle ne devienne substitut de la
biosécurité nous devons envisager de
recourir avec 6 nations massive mais
celle-ci ne peut se mettre en place sans
l'aide de l'État qui doit soutenir la
filière avicole dans cette démarche
la vaccination doit se faire voler par
vos live avec un coût unitaire du vaccin
très élevé en outre on devra ajouter un
monitoring post vaccination
particulièrement lourd et onéreux et
cela afin de garantir la crédibilité et
l'efficacité de la stratégie vaccinale
retenue compte tenu de ces conditions
décrites monsieur le ministre
envisagez-vous les mises en place d'un
plan visant à soutenir financièrement
nos éleveurs lors du déploiement de la
vaccination je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Marc
fenault ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Fabien Lainé
merci de votre question qui me permet de
faire le point sur l'influence avia
d'avoir le point d'étape sur l'influenza
elle-même
je vous rappelle que à l'issue de
l'épisode de l'année dernière nous
avions eu plus de 1400 foyers nous
sommes à date avec un peu plus de 310
foyers ce qui est quand même alors je
pense à tous les éleveurs touchés pour
qui c'est parfois le deuxième le
troisième ou voir plus d'épisodes mais
c'est quand même une meilleure nouvelle
que l'année précédente alors que nous
nourrissions à date en tout cas que nous
nourrissions des inquiétudes l'an
dernier puisque on sait très bien que
l'influence a été restée endémique
premier élément deuxième élément on a
été à la hauteur je crois y compris de
l'accompagnement des éleveurs et compris
des en termes d'indemnisation puisque
plus d'un milliard d'euros ont été
prévus pour l'indemnisation de la
période qui courait en 2021 et en 2022
et que nous avons remis en place le même
dispositif alors qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire désormais la première chose faut
saluer le plan Adour alors si vous avez
dit vous avez raison de salut l'action
du gouvernement mais c'est un plan qui a
été monté avec les éleveurs
et qui a été voulu par les éleveurs qui
étaient un plan au fond de
désensification c'est-à-dire dans les
périodes les plus à risque des 100
janvier de faire en sorte qu'on ne
repeuple pas tout de suite les élevages
pour éviter les périodes où il y a le
plus de risques de contamination et ça a
plutôt marché puisque dans la grande
zone Sud-Ouest il y avait en moyenne 300
foyers il y en a que 20 cette année qui
sont constatés on n'est pas complètement
au bout de l'épisode mais enfin en tout
cas on peut constater que ça a été dans
le bon sens l'objectif c'est de
prolonger ces mesures là et donc on aura
un accompagnement financier ça nous
paraît important de le faire premier
objectif deuxième objectif de penser la
même chose sur d'autres zones de
regarder comment on peut le faire y
compris pour pas préserver le patrimoine
génétique qui sert pour les canards qui
est en Pays de Loire et qui est menacé
par l'influenza en pays Loire du fait
des épisodes récents puis troisième
élément j'y viens la vaccination nous
avons les résultats à la vaccination qui
vont arriver d'ici le courant du mois de
mars on a commencé à déployer un plan
parce qu'il faut faire de la logistique
de la prévisibilité sur ces sujets là on
a j'ai annoncé que le le gouvernement
l'état prendre en charge une partie de
la vaccination et deuxième élément on a
besoin de travailler sur les normes de
commerce pourquoi parce qu'il y a des
échanges internationaux qui sont soumis
parfois à des règles de vaccination
faudrait pas que ça vienne obérer nos
capacités d'export voilà les sujets sur
lesquels nous travaillons merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Aymeric salmon
pour le rassemblement national
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
aujourd'hui de très nombreux Français
sont dans la rue comme dans ma
circonscription sur le rond-point
d'emblanc et belote pour vous signifier
dans le calme leur opposition à votre
réforme des retraites les syndicats nous
annoncent le blocage de la France ce
blocage est en fait une coproduction
vous en êtes la première responsable
c'est vous qui avez choisi de faire
passer votre néfaste
inutile et injuste réformes des
retraites par un projet de loi de
finance rectificative de la sécurité
sociale et ainsi limiter la durée du
débat ce débat nous ne l'avons même pas
eu dans cette hémicycle à cause de
l'obstruction de l'extrême gauche dupes
mais c'est bien vous la responsable de
ce choix je disais co-production car je
n'oublie pas que l'extrême gauche du
Pesse en avril le dernier appelé à voter
pour Emmanuel Macron dont le seul
programme était justement le recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite
et même récemment ici lorsqu'une motion
référendaire a été discutée l'extrême
gauche du Pesse parce qu'ils avaient
perdu un pile ou face à préférer
déserter que voter cette notion
référendaire
collègue de l'extrême gauche lupus vous
êtes co-responsable de cette case
sociale qui s'annonce aujourd'hui madame
la Première ministre pour ne pas
entraîner la France dans un blocage qui
pourrait s'avérer dramatique pour notre
économie déjà bien malmenée par votre
politique vous avez une solution et vous
pouvez sortir par le haut organisez un
référendum alors ma question est simple
madame la Première ministre quand
allez-vous proposer au président de la
République comme vous le permet
l'article 11 de la Constitution de
demander aux Français de trancher par
référendum si oui ou non il souhaite
l'application de votre projet de loi
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau
ocratique du gouvernement merci madame
la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député seulement
il n'y a pas lieu et encore moins dans
cette hémicycle d'envisager qu'il puisse
y avoir une sorte de conflit de
légitimité entre la légitimité de la rue
et la légitimité de la représentation
nationale vous avez été monsieur le
député comme l'ensemble des
parlementaires ici dans cette émission
désigné par le peuple pour pouvoir faire
la loi amender la loi votez la loi
proposer ou vous opposer je dis ça par
rapport à certains discours qui
tendraient à compter et à comparer la
légitimité de l'un et l'autre nous avons
un fonctionnement dans notre république
démocratique qui repose sur le respect
des institutions dans la même veine
monsieur le député vous avez eu
l'occasion de soumettre et de défendre
ici même dans cette hémicycle une motion
Visante à imposer ou à proposer un
référendum monsieur le député vous avez
été battu au vote et je ne doute pas une
seconde que vous n'ayez envie d'en
contester le résultat vous avez eu cette
opportunité les parlementaires ont fait
le choix de se rassembler pour examiner
cette importance projet de loi pour
l'avenir de notre modèle social vous
déplorez et je peux le faire avec vous
le fait que les débats n'aient pas pu
aller à leur terme non pas monsieur le
député comme vous l'insinuez parce que
le la durée accordée au débat aurait été
rabougri il n'y a jamais eu un temps de
débat aussi long sur une réforme de
retrait dans la 5e République que le
temps accordé dans cette émission ainsi
qu'au Sénat avec plus de senteurs
accordés au Sénat et je note que les
sénateurs se réunissent jour et nuit
jusqu'à 3h du matin hier pour pouvoir
adopter déjà jusqu'à l'article 6 ils
vont entamer aujourd'hui je le souhaite
les fameuses articles 7 permettant au
débat démocratique de se poursuivre nous
respectons la contestation sociale sous
toutes ses formes sous forme de
manifestations ou de grève évidemment et
nous rappelons notre ambition réformer
le pays c'est-à-dire aussi éviter que ce
pays soit paralysé bloqué et que nous
puissions avancer collectivement
votre entêtement est un message clair
pour les français s'il souhaite un
retour en arrière sur ce projet de loi
ils n'ont qu'un seul moyen voté Marine
Le Pen en 2027
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Pascal Martin pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre vous avez
affirmé hier en interview que la volonté
du gouvernement était d'atteindre
l'égalité salariale et qu'il fallait se
battre pour l'obtenir la réforme des
retraites pénalisent les femmes et
méprisent leur travail même monsieur
Riester le concept de la vue même de
monsieur le ministre du Travail et je le
cite le débat sur la retraite pour les
femmes est extrêmement compliqué à la
veille de la Journée internationale des
droits des femmes et 40 ans après la loi
Rudy les femmes touchent toujours en
moyenne un quart de salaire en moins que
les hommes contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit hier elles sont toujours
contraintes autant partielles et aux
carrières hachées selon vous les femmes
peuvent aujourd'hui concilier vie
professionnelle et vie familiale ah bon
dans ce cas pourquoi les jeunes mers
sont-elles si souvent contraintes de
passer à temps partiel pourquoi les
femmes s'appauvrissent lorsqu'elles
deviennent mère et surtout pourquoi
votre gouvernement ne fait rien pour
améliorer l'accès à l'emploi des mères
où sont les places en crèche et le vrai
service public de la petite enfance dont
nous avons besoin de ce fait le report
de l'âge de la retraite de l'âge de
départ à la retraite touchera plus
fortement les femmes que les hommes rien
n'est clair sur les dispositifs pouvant
atténuer ses effets alors que la droite
sénatoriale semble bien décidé à
intégrer des politiques natalistes
rétrogrades et sexistes à cette réforme
le gouvernement remet ce débat au
prochain budget de la Sécurité sociale
j'ai évoqué plusieurs exemples notamment
celui de Pascaline 52 ans au chômage et
désespéré par le refus d'embauger
employeurs d'autres femmes m'ont dit
qu'elles vivaient la même situation et
qu'elle ne comprenait pas votre
acharnement mensonge après mensonge les
femmes sont dans la rue parce qu'elle
n'en peuvent plus et les hommes sont
avec elle car eux aussi n'en peuvent
plus aujourd'hui vous bloquez le pays
les femmes vont moins perdre que prévu
mais elles vont perdre quand même
déclarent monsieur Martinez pouvons-nous
compter sur votre engagement pourquoi
enfin les femmes puissent vivre
dignement de leur travail de leur
retraite merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du stop de ministre du
Travail de l'insertion et du plein
emploi merci madame la présidente madame
la députée Martin finalement de toute
votre question nous pouvons tomber
d'accord sur peut-être un point
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes restent un défi ça
reste un objectif et ça reste un défi
beaucoup a été fait par ce gouvernement
et par ceux qui l'ont précédé beaucoup
ont été fait pour l'accès des femmes à
l'emploi c'est une bonne nouvelle
beaucoup a été fait pour l'accès des
femmes à l'éducation c'est évidemment
une bonne nouvelle c'est une marge de
l'histoire qu'il faut continuer qu'il
faut accélérer dans le précédent
quinquennat dans celui qui a précédé
dans celui encore avant chaque fois les
majorités qui se sont succédées ont
adopté des textes permettant d'apporter
leurs pierres à la construction de
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes vous avez à
l'occasion de votre je vous ai écouté
madame je vous ai écouté à l'occasion de
chacune de ces politiques l'objectif a
toujours été le même faire en sorte que
l'égalité soit au rendez-vous et puisque
vous avez évoqué la question des
retraites ça me permet d'apporter deux
précisions la première précision c'est
que notre système de retraite aussi
complexe soit-il n'est pas un système de
retraite qui est injuste avec les femmes
aucune règle du système de retraite ne
discrimine les femmes ou les hommes
notre système de retraite lorsqu'il
calcule la pension d'une assurée il
tient compte des inégalités accumulées
tout au long de la vie et donc le
véritable chantier pour réduire ses
inégalités c'est de travailler sur
l'égalité professionnelle la deuxième
chose que je veux souligner et qui va à
rebourser d'autres questions c'est que
avec cette réforme des retraites nous
demandons un effort aux françaises et
aux Français qui consiste à travailler
un peu plus pour garantir le système par
répartition mais lorsque vous regardez
l'étude d'impact lorsque vous regardez
les projections qui sont faites la
répartition de cet effort entre les
femmes et entre les hommes c'est 55 ans
et nous y avons veillé avec madame la
Première ministre nous travaillons pour
cela mais j'ai une interrogation quand
je vous écoute madame les députés si
vous êtes aussi attaché à l'égalité
professionnelle femme homme que cela
pourquoi est-ce que votre famille
politique n'a jamais soutenu
les propositions de loi les projets de
loi portés par cette majorité pour
améliorer l'égalité jamais vous ne les
avez soutenus c'est cette majorité qui
travaille pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé Solignac
pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre le président de la
République a annoncé à la surprise
générale qu'il présidera demain un
hommage à la mémoire de Gisèle Halimi à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des droits des femmes cette initiative a
suscité beaucoup de réactions
d'incompréhensions et même parfois de
colère madame la Première ministre si
Gisèle à limite est encore des nôtres
elle serait en ce moment aux côtés de
celles et ceux qui battent le pavé pour
dénoncer une réforme dont les premières
victimes seront les femmes
nombre de ses proches dénoncent une
instrumentalisation politique et une
opération de communication grossière
Gisèle avait mis amené tant de combat
que nul ne peut l'enfermer dans une
cause unique mais chacun sait qu'elle a
surtout défendu avec acharnement la
dignité des femmes et des peuples chacun
sait combien son engagement force le
respect et l'admiration de millions de
Françaises et de français chacun sait
aussi que les batailles qui furent les
siennes ont contribué à faire grandir
les idéaux de la République dans ces
conditions Gisèle Halimi mérite mieux
qu'un hommage en forme de provocation et
la seule reconnaissance qui soit à la
hauteur de son engagement serait de
décider enfin de son entrée au Panthéon
le président de la République doit
mettre fin à des atermoiements qui sont
vécus comme du mépris par ceux qui ont
la conviction que la place de cette
femme au parcours de vie exceptionnelle
se trouve légitimement aux côtés de
celles et ceux qui sont l'honneur de la
France les tergiversations du président
de la République ne sont pas recevables
pas une femme pas un homme qui ne se
soit tout entier consacré à tant de
grandes causes ne peut prétendre
consensus et c'est dans ce temple de
tous les dieux qu'il conviennent
désormais de faire entrer cette grande
femme c'est donc avec solennité que je
vous demande madame la Première ministre
si vous allez enfin œuvrer pour
favoriser l'entrée au panthéon de Gisèle
Halimi
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
Isabelle Rome ministre délégué chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Solignac je vous
remercie de votre question le 8 mars
journée internationale et droits des
femmes est une occasion chaque année de
constater que le combat pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes restent
d'actualité et face à la montée de la
pensée conservatrice nous devons
protéger nos citoyens nos concitoyennes
protéger leurs droits les plus
fondamentaux en rendant un hommage
national à Gisèle Halimi le président de
la République a choisi d'honorer une
femme de combat une pionnière du
féminisme une avocate courageuse dans la
plaidoirie au procès de Bobigny restera
gravé dans le marbre de nos mémoires
l'avancée société l'avancée sociétale
fondamentale pour les droits des femmes
que constitue l'accès à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse mérite elle
aussi d'être gravée dans le marbre de
notre plus puissant texte républicain
et c'est ainsi que nous protégerons nos
filles de toutes les idées rétrogrades
qui pourraient un jour avoir drat petit
et dans notre République le plan en
faveur de l'égalité que je présenterai
demain au côté de la première ministre a
été élaborée dans cet esprit autour de 4
axes la lutte contre les violences
l'égalité économique la santé des femmes
la culture de l'égalité je pense que
Gisèle Halimi aurait apprécié ce plan je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à Madame Charlotte
Parmentier le coq pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre du
travail et du plein emploi monsieur le
ministre alors que les travaux sur le
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
se poursuivent au Sénat ceci permettront
je l'espère de démontrer que cette
réforme comporte des mesures favorables
aux femmes mesure que nous n'avons
malheureusement pas pu aborder à cause
de la regrettable obstruction opérée par
la France insoumise je veux parler de la
revalorisation des petites retraites qui
bénéficiera très majoritairement aux
femmes je veux parler de la prise en
compte des congés parentaux qui
bénéficiera très majoritairement aux
femmes je veux parler de la prise en
compte des congés proches aidants qui
bénéficiera également très
majoritairement aux femmes
de plus la majorité au travers de
plusieurs amendements portés notamment
par Véronique Riotton et Marie-Pierre
rixin ainsi que par les groupes modem et
horizons souhaitent enrichir le texte et
nous espérons que les débats au Sénat
permettront de concrétiser ces avancées
de nouvelles pistes sont également à
l'étude notamment celle d'une surcotte
pour les femmes ayant eu un enfant et
atteint un nombre suffisant deux
trimestres avant l'âge de départ à la
retraite
pouvez-vous sur ce point monsieur le
ministre nous indiquait la vie du
gouvernement nous le savons les
retraites des femmes sont moins élevées
tout simplement parce qu'elles sont le
reflet de carrière moins bien rémunérés
et souvent impacté par leur vie
familiale
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
indiquait quelle mesure vous envisagez
de mettre en oeuvre pour poursuivre le
combat contre les inégalités salariales
entre les hommes et les femmes et pour
permettre aux femmes d'accéder au même
carrière que les hommes je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft au
ministre du Travail de l'insertion et du
président madame la député vous
m'interrogez sur la situation des femmes
au moment du départ à la retraite et
notamment sur ce que nous voulons faire
pour faire en sorte que l'égalité
professionnelle soit au rendez-vous afin
de réduire ses inégalités de pensions le
texte que nous vous présentons tel que
nous l'avons élaboré avec madame la
Première ministre prévoit un certain
nombre de mesures que vous avez évoqué
je regrette moi aussi que votre
assemblée n'est plus les examiner
l'intégration de trimestres cotisés de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les parents
foyers donc de congé parental à la fois
dans le calcul de l'éligibilité à la
pension minimum mais aussi dans le
calcul de l'éligibilité à des parents
anticipés au titre du dispositif de
carrière longue le fait que nous vous
que nous souhaitions créer une
association une assurance vieillesse les
aidons parce que nous savons que les
aidants sont souvent des aidants et
c'est une manière aussi forte d'aider
les femmes des amendements portés par la
majorité je pense à l'amendement de
Monsieur Vigier sur l'intégration au
titre du modem sur l'intégration des
indemnités journalières d'avant 2012
dans le calcul des retraites pour les
revaloriser je pense à l'amendement du
groupe horizon mais aussi du groupe
communiste pour faire en sorte de mieux
obtenir compte des difficultés liées à
la perte d'un enfant et au deuil d'un
enfant en bas âge avec les conséquences
que cela aujourd'hui sur l'octroi ou le
maintien de la majoration de 10% pour le
troisième enfant autant de sujet
d'avancé donc j'espère évidemment que le
Sénat viendra les concrétiser qu'ensuite
votre assemblée pourra les confirmer la
majorité sénatoriale a proposé un
dispositif que nous regardons avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de bienveillance je
m'explique en un mot de plus en plus de
fans au moment du départ à la retraite à
qui des trimestres types de leur
carrière professionnelle mais aussi au
titre de leur maternité et lorsque leur
carrière professionnelle est complète
ces trimestres peuvent sembler moins
utiles la majorité sénatoriale propose
que d'une part les femmes ayant une
carrière hachée et nous savons sont plus
nombreuses à être ainsi concernés
puisqu'on continue à bénéficier ces
majorations durée pour éviter la décote
et reconstituer leur carrière mais que
dans le même temps celle qui aurait
atteint la durée de cotisation requise
de fait du fait de cette trimestre de
maternité puisse à partir de 63 ans
bénéficier d'une surcote et que ce qui
est perdu en temps puis cette gagne en
surcote de la pension sur le principe
nous y sommes favorables et nous allons
continuer à travailler avec eux je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre
vincentet pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
monsieur le ministre le 1er janvier 2023
la zone A faible émission du Grand Lyon
est entre en vigueur pour les voitures
des particuliers après une période
pédagogique de 4 mois la cause affichée
on peut le dire est indiscutable
cependant combattre les particules fines
ne peut se faire au détriment des plus
modestes des travailleurs qui se lèvent
tôt qui sont eux les grands oubliés de
cette politique écologique punitive car
les classes populaires ne polluent pas
volontairement elle ne peuvent pas faire
autrement on ne pollue pas
volontairement quand on habite en
banlieue on ne peut pas volontairement
quand la métropole de Lyon ajourne
l'extension des lignes de métro quelle
hypocrisie de la part des dirigeants
verts de vouloir sanctionner les plus
modestes qui ne peuvent pas s'acheter
une voiture neuve ou une voiture
électrique au risque de les reléguer
dans les banlieues en leur interdisant
ainsi l'entrée dans les grandes villes y
compris pour aller y travailler
face à la mobilisation d'une grande
partie de la population et des élus
locaux la métropole de Lyon a annoncé
ralentir la cadence par rapport au
calendrier initial mais ce n'est vous en
conviendrez que reporter le problème que
comptez-vous faire monsieur le ministre
pour mettre fin à la sourde colère qui
gronde face à cette écologie punitive
qui creuse des inégalités sociales entre
les centres urbains et les habitants des
quartiers populaires ainsi que des
centaines de villes moyennes comme Dreux
pour Paris ou Villefranche-sur-Saône
pour Lyon il ne faut pas que ces aid et
feux deviennent un outil de ségrégation
et d'assignation à résidence je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Vincent des
d'abord j'aimerais vous remercier pour
la manière dont vous avez commencé à
poser cette question en expliquant que
le combat contre les particules fines
contre les morts qui sont liées aux
dioxyde d'azote il n'avait pas de
frontières et que nous retrouvions dans
ce combat je voudrais vous rappeler que
ces éléments qui sont une mesure de
santé publique ça n'est pas une
invention française ça existe dans 270
villes européennes et vous l'avez dit il
y a des difficultés potentielles pour
les plus modestes tu en as aussi compte
tenu de cette pollution parce que on
sait que les premières victimes de cette
pollution atmosphérique ceux qui sont en
première ligne sont à la fois les
personnes âgées les enfants et ceux qui
sont les plus mal logés mais votre
question j'ai le sentiment qu'elle porte
plutôt sur les conditions d'application
à l'intérieur de la métropole de Lyon
que sur le dispositif en lui-même et
vous me donnez l'occasion de revenir sur
l'épisode de communication qui a eu lieu
il y a quelques semaines dans cette
métropole avec le président de la
métropole expliquant que à cause de
l'état il était obligé de différer et de
renoncer à cette ambition de quoi
s'agit-il
il a annoncé
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Vincent des
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
simplement il est important quand même
de voir que s'il y a des applications
qui sont plus strictes encore que la loi
avec justement dans la métropole de Lyon
le fait d'interdire demain les véhicules
critères de nous avons une véritable
bombe sociale devant nous parce que nous
empêcherons demain des milliers de
personnes précaires devenir travailler
dans les métropoles et nous continuerons
à fracturer nos territoires et ce n'est
pas acceptable et nous devons travailler
là-dessus pour les plus précaires je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre Daredevil
pour le groupe GDR madame la Première
ministre
c'est le moment
c'est maintenant alors peut-être pas
tout de suite peut-être dans quelques
heures quoique finalement l'Assemblée
nationale serait un bon lieu pour faire
vos annonces
c'est un grand jour de grève
des femmes et des hommes manifestent
massivement à nouveau dans tout le pays
contre la réforme des retraites n'allait
pas croire que cela réponde à une sorte
de folklore celles et ceux qui refusent
d'autres projets sont déterminés ils ont
bien compris les enjeux il elles veulent
être respectés depuis des semaines et
des semaines en réalité vous n'avez
convaincu personne finalement ils sont
presque tous et toutes ici dans cette
hémicycle les partisans de cette réforme
il y en a quelques dizaines au Sénat il
y a le président de la République aussi
à l'Élysée qui regarde défiler les
pancartes aujourd'hui et peut-être
également le Bureau Exécutif du Medef
même si il n'ose pas trop s'envoyer
alors ces derniers jours vous avez fait
les fonds de tiroirs des arguments du
soft qui peut des arguments de la
dernière chance la réforme serait
soi-disant une réforme de gauche et le
mouvement social nuirait au climat
vous avez perdu madame la Première
ministre la bataille des retraites il
apparaît clairement que votre réforme
est inutile injuste et fondamentalement
régressive ces deux ans de plus ou des
pensions en berne vous avez perdu la
bataille des retraites par respect pour
l'esprit de la démocratie et de la
République vous devez l'admettre il n'y
a pas d'autres
issus raisonnables que le retrait du
texte ne continuez pas à tenter le coup
arrêter le passage en force le président
est vous-même semblait en faire une
question d'autorité si vous voulez avoir
une chance de restaurer quelques
autorités quelques possibilités d'action
de renouer le lien avec le pays il faut
montrer que vous savez écouter alors
comment voyez-vous la suite et comment
pouvons-nous vous aider à annoncer au
plus vite le retrait
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail de l'insertion et du plein
emploi merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le député Pierre d'arriville
vous nous interrogez monsieur le député
sur la réforme des retraites j'ai bien
compris que vous appeliez au retrait je
crains de vous décevoir dans cette
réponse mais pourquoi est-ce que nous
faisons cette réforme et pourquoi est-ce
que nous savons que cette réforme est
difficile nous la faisons d'abord parce
que cette réforme est nécessaire elle
est nécessaire parce que le système de
retraite est déficitaire il est
déficitaire lourdement structurellement
avec 12 milliards et demi de déficit dès
2027 13 milliards et demi en 2030 et 20
milliards d'euros par an à partir 2035
et cette réforme est nécessaire pour
préserver notre système de retraite par
répartition pour préserver la solidarité
intergénérationnelle elle est difficile
aussi dans le même temps parce que c'est
une réforme qui demande des efforts des
efforts aux Français avec deux ans de
travail en plus pas pour tous
progressivement bien sûr en tenant
compte de la pénibilité en tenant compte
des carrières longues en tenant compte
des inégalités de carrière qui déjà
traversent la société
avec madame la Première ministre que cet
effort soit le plus justement réparti et
c'est en cela que la réforme est juste
d'abord parce que l'effort est justement
réparti mais aussi parce que cette
réforme crée des droits des droits en
termes de relèvement des plus petites
pensions des droits en termes de
meilleures protection face aux
carreracher des droits en termes
d'amélioration de la situation des
femmes et des hommes vous me dites
monsieur le député que nous sommes allés
chercher des arguments le plus loin
possible nous ne sommes pas les traînois
en réalité nous avons regardé autour de
nous et nous avons vu que dans tous les
pays qui nous entourent qu'ils soient
libéraux qu'ils soient socio-démocrate
la perspective de l'âge de départ a déjà
été relevée là 65 ans là 66 ans là 67
ans et si j'étais malicieux je vous
dirais que même en Espagne c'est un
ministre du Travail communiste qui met
en oeuvre une réforme certes voter il y
a longtemps mais qui depuis le 1er
janvier fait que l'âge officiel
d'ouverture des droits est fixée à 66
ans vous le voyez monsieur le député
nous ne sommes pas une île nous ne
sommes pas isolés nous avons un déficit
démographique nous avons un déficit
financier nous avons besoin de faire
cette réforme et le Sénat dans les
prochaines heures va continuer à
l'examiner avant que vous soyez à
l'Assemblée nationale un nouveau saisie
avec toujours cette même objectif la
nécessité et la justice merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur Daredevil
2 secondes
c'est une réponse à la hauteur du
mouvement social
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout pour le
groupe iote merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse madame la Première
ministre madame ouvrier employé
fonctionnaire étudiant les Français les
Français sont dans la rue j'en reviens
ils sont des milliers et dans les
dignités ils sont dans la rue bien sûr
pour contre votre réforme mais aussi
mais pas que ils sont surtout excédés
par vos choix et cédé par votre manque
de considération et de respect excédé
par vos politiques les plus injustes les
unes que les autres LCD de vous entendre
ressasser que malgré tout va bien alors
que nous étudions font la queue au resto
du coeur alors que l'inflation rend la
vie de chacun impossible alors que le
réseau des Banques Alimentaires compte
quand même un tiers de bénéficiaires en
plus dont 18% d'actifs oui madame la
Première ministre je vous parle bien de
notre jeunesse je vous parle bien des
gens qui bossent et des petits retraités
oui comprenez le monde du travail est
excédé de important de dire que tout va
bien qui va falloir encore faire des
efforts votre réforme des retraites
c'est l'injustice de trop je vous le
demande pourquoi faire payer au seul
travailleur le prix de cette réforme et
pour qui pour une petite minorité de
privilégiés alors c'est non vos
dogmatismes mais vos certitudes ça
suffit un peuple qui a bâti son histoire
sur un idéal de justice c'est levé il
vous dit non à cette réforme vous n'avez
pas le droit de lui opposer un débat
bafoué des procédures législatives
tronquées des 49-3 en bis répétita vous
n'avez pas le droit de paralyser la
France en témoignant notre peuple mépris
est suffisance la France qu'on aime ce
n'est pas la France qui réussit pour une
poignée la France qu'on aime elle est
dans la rue aujourd'hui c'est la France
du respect de la considération cette
France là je m'en fait modestement le
porte-parole quand allez-vous retirer
votre réforme
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du socle
de ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente
il n'y a jamais de bons moments faut
faire une réforme des retraites nous
l'avons entendu des dizaines de fois il
n'y a jamais de bons moments parce que
finalement personne n'a jamais le
courage de faire cette réforme je l'ai
dit à l'instant un monsieur le député de
la vraie ville il y a une nécessité
d'avancer il y a une nécessité de faire
nous sommes dans une situation qui fait
que la démographie parle pour la réforme
dans les années 70 trois cotisants pour
un retraité aujourd'hui 1,7 cotisants
pour un retraité une perspective de
déficit structurel durable que
devrions-nous faire attendre si nous
attendons si nous ne faisons pas la
réforme le déficit continue de se
creuser ce n'est pas l'absence de
réforme qui freinera le creusement du
déficit si nous attendons deux ans trois
ans quatre ans de plus les marches à
franchir pour retourner l’équilibre
seront toujours plus hautes et la
difficulté à mettre la réforme sera
toujours plus importante donc nous
agissons nous le faisons aux
responsabilités nous le faisons d'autant
plus son responsabilité que nous le
faisons dans la droite ligne des
engagements pris par le Président de la
République devant les Français à
l'occasion de la dernière campagne
présidentielle nous le faisons en
faisant en sorte que les forces soient
répartis le plus justement possible et
nous ne faisons pas en étant sourd nous
avons entendu nous avons travaillé
pendant des mois et des mois autour de
la concertation et la réforme que nous
présentons a évolué au fil du temps
évoluer pour mieux protéger les plus
fragiles évoluer pour m'y prendre en
compte les carrières les plus âgées
évoluer pour mieux prendre en compte
plusieurs professionnels surtout mieux
la prévenir tout ça nous l'avons fait
avec la concertation elle n'a pas permis
de surmonter tous les désaccords mais
nous l'avons fait nous continuons à
avancer vous dites en femme chez le
député ce n'est pas le moment parce
qu'il y a d'autres difficultés il y a
des difficultés de pouvoir d'achat il y
a des difficultés d'inflation mais dans
ce cas là où étiez-vous pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas voté les textes
budgétaires qui permettent la mise en
oeuvre du chèque carburant pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas soutenu les mesures
portées par le gouvernement pour faire
en sorte que le pouvoir d'achat des
Français soit mieux défendu c'est en
allant sur tous les terrains qu'on est
efficace nous agissons pour les Français
nous protégeons leur pouvoir d'achat et
nous garantissons l'avenir du système de
retraite je vous remercie mon cher
collègue monsieur Brico
un monsieur le monsieur le ministre je
suis quand même désolé moi j'appelle pas
ça du courage de sacrifier le régime
social de nos ouvriers pendant deux ans
et puis je pense que votre retraite
toute façon je pense qu'il faut la
retirer si ni le bon moment c'est pas
c'est pas le bon tempo c'est le ministre
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Monique Bora pour
le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
la question t'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la santé et de la prévention
de nombreux rapports dont celui du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et diverses communications
ont attiré l'attention sur la nécessité
de prendre en compte le genre dans nos
politiques publiques en matière de santé
il arrive en effet que les politiques
publiques
sont en effet marqués par des préjugés
et des stéréotypes liées au genre et
influencent la prise en compte des
signes cliniques et retarde les
diagnostics nécessaires sans lesquels
les stratégies de prévention et de
traitement ne peuvent être définies les
maladies considérées comme étant
classées masculine ou féminine
représente des réalités qu'il faut mieux
en ces trois exemples les maladies
cardiovasculaires apanage des maladies
dites masculines dont les femmes sont
les premières victimes
l'ostéoporose de maladie dites féminines
mais qui touchent aussi les hommes et le
papillomavirus est en réputé lui
touchait exclusivement les femmes des
stéréotypes donc il faut dénoncer les
conditions de vie sociale économique et
les facteurs environnementaux doivent
être pris en compte également sachant
qu'ils impactent de manière différente
les hommes et les femmes ces dernières
étant plus touchées par la précarité
notamment partant de ces constats
comment Monsieur le Ministre allait plus
loin pour cette prise en compte du genre
et du sexe dans l'élaboration de nos
politiques publiques en matière de santé
et de prévention notamment je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
François brode ministre de la santé et
de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente le dernier
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
ibora la santé des femmes est un enjeu
majeur pour ce gouvernement comme l'a
rappelé ma collègue Isabelle Rome c'est
également je le sais une préoccupation
constante des députés de la majorité et
d'autres députés au niveau de ses bancs
alors permettez-moi de rappeler déjà
quelques mesures qui ont été prises
récemment concernant la santé des femmes
tout d'abord dans le cadre de la du
droit reproductif la prise en charge à
100% de la contraception d'urgence pour
toutes les femmes également dans ce
cadre là la prise en charge à 100% de
dépistage et sans ordonnance des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
pour les garçons et les filles de moins
de 26 ans ces infections étant une des
causes majeures d'infertilité chez la
femme vous l'avez dit le papillomavirus
le 28 février dernier avec le président
de la République nous avons lancé la
campagne de vaccination des garçons et
des filles en 5e contre le
papillonavirus ce virus est responsable
de cancer chez les hommes comme chez les
femmes
et surtout responsable de 100% des
cancers du col de l'utérus qui tuent
encore plus de 1000 femmes par an en
France cette vaccination nous permettra
de l'éradiquer récemment madame la
Première ministre dans le cadre de la
précarité menstruelle à annoncé le
remboursement par la Sécurité Sociale là
aussi à 100% des protections
réutilisables pour les femmes de moins
de 25 ans mais au-delà vous avez raison
il existe un certain nombre de
pathologies pour lesquelles les
symptômes chez la femme sont mal connues
en particulier les pathologies
cardiovasculaires la recherche nous
permet de mieux les connaître maintenant
il convient encore de mieux les déployer
et de mieux les apprendre sur l'ensemble
du territoire
prochainement aussi la PPL de Madame
Josso nous permettra d'entrer dans une
meilleure prise en charge des couples
dont la femme est victime de fausse
couche sur la prévention également je ne
rappellerai pas les spécificités des
rendez-vous prévention puisque c'est
dans cette assemblée que plusieurs
amendements ont amené une spécificité
féminine dans ses rendez-vous de
prévention mais par contre je reviendrai
sur la politique de aller vers
particulièrement importante dans
l'appréhension des femmes et en
particulier dans le cancer du sein
politique que nous allons déployer avec
les médiateurs en santé vous voyez
beaucoup de choses a été faites et il
reste merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur gober Narcisse
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre en cette
journée de mobilisation je vais vous
parler de blocage il y a un an vous
refusiez la proposition de loi que j'ai
défendu avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur le
blocage des prix sur le modèle de ce qui
se fait en outre-mer depuis les prix des
produits de première nécessité et de
l'énergie ont explosé bien loin des 5%
d'inflation dont vous vous targuez 37%
pour la farine 25% pour le riz 33% pour
les steaks hachés surgelés 13% pour le
lait de même les prix du gaz du pétrole
de l'électricité sont toujours en hausse
de plus de 13%. face à l'inflation vous
proposez de faire confiance à la grande
distribution avec un panier
anti-inflation ça me rappelle l'histoire
avec totale à qui vous aviez demandé
poliment de manière républicaine à ce
qu'il fasse un effort résultat 13
milliards de dividendes pour les
actionnaires un record tout va bien tous
vos amis est toujours pas de taxes sur
les super profits plutôt qu'un panier
anti-inflation qui ressemble plus à un
slogan commercial proposé par McKinsey
véritable coup d'épée dans l'eau
notamment pour les plus précaires je
vous propose une solution pour débloquer
la situation bloquer les prix la
pauvreté s'aggrave la fréquentation des
Restos du cœur en hausse de 22 % sur cet
hiver la progression alarmante du nombre
de jeunes à l'aide alimentaire 330
000 SDF en France shift x 2 en disant et
ça continue vous ne pouvez plus refuser
d'agir en renvoyant encore l'idée que
l'État ne pourrait rien il faut bloquer
les prix notamment le prix de
l'électricité comme nous n'avons voté
ici pour les TPE PME et je pense
évidemment au boulanger dont la survie
en dépend alors qu'on nous annonce un
mars rouge pour l'inflation sortez de
vos formules publicitaires de la
start-up nation avec votre trimestre
anti-inflation agissez pendant que les
gens bloquent le pays contre votre
réforme des retraites
bloquez les prix pour ne pas ajouter une
crise sociale une crise humanitaire
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie de
des Finances et de l'Industrie
merci Madame le Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le député
à tous les problèmes économiques de la
nation française vous apportez toujours
les deux mêmes réponses le blocage des
prix ou la taxation des gens et bien
nous sommes opposés aux deux la taxation
des gens parce que je pense que nos
compatriotes en ont assez de payer
toujours plus d'impôts et toujours plus
de taxes et le blocage des prix parce
que le blocage des prix ça veut dire
tout simplement le rationnement de nos
compatriotes sur les biens de première
nécessité nous nous avons pris des
mesures qui nous permettent d'avoir un
des taux d'inflation les plus faibles de
la zone euro nous avons mis en place un
bouclier sur le prix de l'électricité
nous avons mis en place un bouclier sur
les prix du gaz nous avons mis en place
une indemnité carburant transport et le
résultat de tout ça c'est que
l'inflation qui touche tous les pays
développés au monde les États-Unis tous
les pays européens il y a un pays qui
s'en sort mieux que les autres grâce aux
mesures pris par le gouvernement
par cette majorité par la première
ministre c'est la France vous devriez
vous en féliciter
[Applaudissements]
quant au trimestre anti-inflation vous
en pensez ce que vous voulez nos
compatriotes qui font leurs courses
jugeront et ils verront dès que je
trimestre anti-inflation pendant trois
mois ils ont droit à des prix cassés
pendant trois mois les distributeurs
vont faire des efforts sur leur marge à
hauteur de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros pour que nos
compatriotes sur les produits
alimentaires comme sur les produits
premiers nécessités elle est pris les
plus bas possible ils pourront s'y
retrouver avec un logo tricolore
anti-inflation et ils verront dans leur
panier que leur prix baisse réellement
doudou préférons aux garantir la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et les prix
les plus bas possible et les prix les
plus bas possible à ce que vous proposez
c'est à dire le blocage et le
rationnement nous avons également permis
au distributeur dans trois mois de
renégocier les prix avec la grande
industrie de façon à ce que les prix
continuent à baisser dans les mois qui
viennent
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez plus de temps monsieur Julien
Oudoul pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Dupont-Moretti
garde des sceaux monsieur le ministre
dans un récent communiqué le Syndicat de
la magistrature de Mayotte a exprimé son
rejet des lois de la République qui
permettent de lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine au mépris de
la sécurité de nos compatriotes Mahorais
confronté à une criminalité record et
elle a submersion comorienne ce syndicat
d'extrême gauche a dénoncé le lien
pourtant officiel pourtant avéré
pourtant documenté entre
l'ultra-violence et l'immigration alors
que Monsieur Darmanin s'apprête à lancer
une nouvelle opération de communication
pour décaser les clandestins certains
juges
osent parler de chasse au sans-papiers
et de tout répressif allant même jusqu'à
dire que la politique pénale est décidée
par le ministère de l'Intérieur monsieur
le ministre devant la représentation
nationale pouvez-vous condamner
clairement les déclarations anti
républicaines du Syndicat de la
magistrature et garantir que la loi de
la République s'applique partout et en
toute circonstances sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
je vous remercie la parole
est un Monsieur
Eric Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
monsieur madame la Présidente pardon
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député audoul les propos du Syndicat
de la magistrature n'engage que le
Syndicat de la magistrature d'ailleurs
je voudrais vous rappeler que tandis
Mohamed Souali qui est un élu de Mayotte
à vivement protesté pour dire un certain
nombre de choses et rappeler ce que sont
les valeurs de la République notamment
et ce qu'elles impliquent je rappelle
également que les magistrats sont tenus
à un devoir de réserve et je rappelle
enfin que le garde des sceaux vous voyez
dans le système démocratique qui est le
nôtre vous faites non de la tête on
n'est pas en Hongrie ne peut pas
intervenir pour dire au magistrat
comment ils doivent s'exprimer chacun en
pense ce qu'il doit en penser sur
Mayotte je voudrais vous dire que nous
avons envoyé il y a peu de temps un
directeur de service de greffe des
nouveaux greffiers si magistrats déjà
arrivé puisque nous avons vous nous
avons inventé la brigade de l'urgence
neuf contractuelles trois juristes
assistants en 2021 je voudrais
simplement vous dire que nous avons fait
tout cela grâce au budget que vous
n'avez pas voté merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur audoul
monsieur le ministre votre réponse est à
l'image de votre politique pénale
lamentable allez-vous une bonne fois
pour toutes entendre les cris d'alarme
du peuple français à Mayotte allez-vous
une bonne fois pour toutes protéger ce
département français de la submersion
migratoire et de la disparition
allez-vous une bonne fois pour toutes
rétablir l'ordre et la paix pour nos
compatriotes qui subissent les meurtres
à la machette les attaques de bus
scolaire et le communautarisme sauvages
les mahorets ont le cœur qui bat au
rythme de la Marseillaise leur sang
n'est pas rouge il est bleu blanc rouge
abandonné trahi depuis 6 ans par votre
gouvernement ils font massivement
confiance à Marine Le Pen pour rester
des Français avec nous Mayotte et
françaises et le restera à jamais
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
moi d'abord je ne suis pas pour que les
migrants meurent de froid aux frontières
monsieur Odoul avec l'humanité qui vous
caractérise c'est ce qui nous distingue
et deuxièmement vous êtes comme c'est
commentateurs de certaines chaînes
d'information continue il y a CAF faucon
et bla et bla et bla mais voyez-vous
pour aider la justice la police et la
gendarmerie il faut des moyens
supplémentaires et pour ça je le redis
je me suis promis que je le ferai à
chaque fois que je suis interpellé par
vous il faut voter les budgets ça c'est
mieux que bla et bla et bla et bla merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Francesca
Pasquini pour le groupe écologiste merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers collègues elle s'appelait
angélique Valérie Eva Elena Catherine
Manon mangia Magdalena Siem Marie
Camille Laurence Marina Séverine Flora
Neda Valéria
signifie Laure Marie-Antoinette Assia
Elisa Joël Nassera Cathy Fatia ses
prénoms ce sont ceux des femmes qui ont
été massacrées par leur compagnon ou
ex-compagnants depuis le 1er janvier
2023 5 reste encore anonymes je vais
aujourd'hui à la veille de ce 8 mars
leur rendre hommage dans cet enceinte si
j'arrive à les nommer une par une dans
les temps qui m'est imparti c'est
uniquement parce que nous sommes que
début mars d'ici la fin de l'année cette
liste funeste n'aura fait que croître
les trois dernières sont décédés le
week-end dernier en l'espace de deux
jours deux d'entre elles avaient
pourtant déjà déposé plainte pour
violences conjugales toutes ces femmes
n'auraient pas dû mourir et la seule
main qui peut arrêter cette tuerie et
celle de notre justice et de notre
action publique depuis 2017 la lutte
contre toute les violences sexistes et
sexuelles et présentées comme la grande
cause du quinquennat depuis 2017
pourtant pas une année c'est cool sans
comme moi sans femme soit tué par leur
conjoint ou ex-conjoint et encore ce
chiffre ne tient pas compte des suicides
forcés qui restent un fléau invisible
nous ne pouvons plus nous contenter des
effets d'annonce ils nous font enfin un
plan complet de prise en charge globale
de ce sujet une remise à plat de notre
approche des violences intrafamiliales
des féminicides et des conséquences de
ces derniers vous rencontrez
prochainement le Premier ministre
espagnol nous devons nous inspirer
concrètement de ce qui se fait et
fonctionne dans ce pays madame la
Première ministre allez-vous enfin
accéder aux demandes des associations et
investir à autant de ce auteur de ceux
qui seraient nécessaires merci je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
le premier responsable d'un féminicide
madame la députée nous en déplaise c'est
son auteur
et les Espagnols que vous prenez en
modèle et en exemple que j'ai rencontré
ils ont un seuil de féminicides en deçà
desquels ils ne sont pas défendus mais
bien sûr cela ne nous condamne pas aux
fatalisme et nous ne sommes pas
fatalisme parce que vous voyez là encore
la critique le blablabla c'est facile le
nombre de jugements en matière de
violence conjugales à doubler madame la
députée de 2017 à 2021 le nombre de
condamnations 2017 était de 21 1951 il
est passé à 43702 en 2021 la réponse
judiciaire est plus rapide
les procédures de déferlement ont
augmenté de 182 %
205% entre 2017 et 2021 d'éviction du
conjoint des déferlements réponse pénale
plus ferme augmentation des
condamnations plus 100% entre 2017 et
2022 les TGD plus 45%, les ordonnances
de protection plus 153%. alors c'est
facile madame de dire après avoir énoncé
et égrené ces féminicides qui sont
terrifiants le gouvernement ne fait rien
ça n'est pas vrai et madame la Première
ministre a fait deux annoncières ce qui
prouve ce qui prouve madame que nous
avons envie d'aller encore plus loin je
vais vous rappeler un dernier chiffre en
2006 le nombre de féminicides dans ce
pays c'est 179
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Chantal boulot pour
le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères madame la ministre ce
mercredi 8 mars se tiendra la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
d'olhamp de Gouges à Simone Veil en
passant par Simone de Beauvoir notre
nation a toujours été à l'avant-garde de
la pensée et des combats féministes au
mois d'avril 2022 le président de la
République a réaffirmé vouloir faire de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la grande cause de son quinquennat notre
majorité s'engage aussi dans cette voie
en affirmant sa volonté d'inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
car l'actualité nous démontre que
partout où le climat politique se durcit
les droits des femmes sont les premiers
bafoués en Afghanistan ou le régime
taliban a interdit toute éducation femme
en plus de les avoir exclu de la voie de
la vie politique publique en Iran ou
certains sont allés jusqu'à empoisonner
des centaines d'écolières pour susciter
la peur et tenter de faire taire ce
slogan émancipateur femme vie liberté
l'Ukraine enfin où les Nations unies à
test que les femmes sont victimes de
violences sexuelles insupportables de la
part de l'agresseur russe
fidèle à son histoire la France peut et
doit continuer à jouer un rôle dans la
protection des femmes
madame la ministre à la veille de cette
journée du 8 mars pouvez-vous réaffirmer
ici que la diplomatie française
gardienne historique de la défense des
droits de l'homme dans le monde
continuera de s'attacher tout autant à
la protection des droits de la femme je
vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés mesdames la député
Boulou merci de votre question car la
France en effet sonore historiquement
devrait pour les droits des femmes et
elle continuera résolument de le faire
notamment aujourd'hui où ils sont
effectivement menacés dans trop de
régions du monde c'est le cas en Iran où
les femmes engagées pour la liberté ont
été réprimés et vous en souvenez
peut-être madame la député j'ai remis à
titre posthume à ma famille le prix
franco-allemand des droits de l'homme
c'est aussi le cas en Afghanistan bien
sûr les femmes et les filles sont peu à
peu effacés de la vie publique c'est le
cas en Ukraine où nous soutenant les
victimes de viol et celles si nombreuses
qui ont dû fuir leur foyer
nous continuerons de porter un message
public fort comme je l'ai fait à l'ONU à
Genève il y a quelques jours
d'apporter une aide ciblée mais aussi
d'accroître la pression et aujourd'hui
veuille du 8 mars l'Union européenne
vient de sanctionner des responsables de
violation contre les droits des femmes
en Russie en Afghanistan en Iran
Birmanie en Syrie en Soudan du Sud tout
responsable qui ont porté atteinte au
droit des femmes et que nous
sanctionnons par le gel de leurs avoir
et l'interdiction de travailler je dois
citer l'une des personnes concernées et
pardonnez-moi de trouver que son titre
laisse songeur c'est le ministre afghan
du vice et de la vertu madame la députée
nous luttons donc partout pour que
l'égalité entre les femmes c'est des
hommes deviennent une réalité c'est bien
le sens de la diplomatie féministe que
nous continuerons de mener et bien sûr
je ferai comme la première ministre pour
ma part de nouvelles annonces demain à
l'occasion du 8 mars mais vous pourrez
voir dès aujourd'hui sur les grilles des
photos des combattantes de la liberté
que nous accueillons et que nous aidons
et que nous soutenons dans le cadre du
programme qui leur permet de passer
plusieurs mois en France qui s'appelle
le programme Marianne et nous les
honorons merci madame la députée je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est à Madame Marie-Noëlle Battistel pour
le groupe socialiste merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
demain 8 mars nous célébrons la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
de la lutte pour l'égalité partout en
France et dans le monde les acteurs
institutionnels associatifs économiques
les citoyens se mobiliseront pour dire
leur engagement pour l'égalité rappeler
leurs exigences et marquer le chemin
qu'il reste à faire les déclarations
ministérielles et présidentielles ne
feront aucune fausse note dans le
concert des bonnes intentions de ceux
qui veulent agir pour que les droits des
femmes soient renforcés pour autant les
grandes déclarations ne suffisent pas
elles sont louables mais ne résistent
pas au poids des faits et des intentions
vos intentions pour la réforme des
retraites nous les connais les femmes
paieront un lourd tribu le ministre
Franck Riester lui-même la reconnu il a
raison les femmes ont des carrières in
interrompues doivent travailler plus
longtemps 19% doivent atteindre l'âge
d'annulation de la décote pour liquider
leurs droits contre 10% pour les hommes
le bénéfice des trimestres de maternité
qui permet à de nombreuses femmes de
partir à taux plein à 62 ans sera annulé
par le report de l'âge légal à 64 ans
pour 100000 d'entre elles le dispositif
carrière longue et votre désormais
célèbre retraite à 1200 euros ne
concernera que très peu de femmes en
définitive votre réforme est encore plus
d'inégalité pour les femmes et si
finalement l'égalité salariale
permettant d'augmenter les cotisations
étaient une partie de la solution plutôt
que d'augmenter la durée de cotisation
agissez en permettant aux femmes de
gagner autant que les hommes et ainsi de
cotiser davantage ce qui serait
réellement une réforme de progrès une
réforme de gauche madame la Première
ministre ma question est donc simple le
gouvernement va-t-il rejoindre Laurent
de ceux qui veulent faire de l'égalité
famome une réalité en renonçant à cette
réforme
inutile et injuste surtout pour les
femmes allez-vous agir pour l'égalité
salariale aujourd'hui plus que jamais
ces deux sujets sont liés je vous
remercie ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
travail et du plein emploi merci
tout à l'heure de répondre à Madame la
député par tenter le coq en rappelant
plusieurs choses d'abord la réforme que
nous présentons permet de mieux prendre
en compte le caractère malheureusement
haché de la carrière de beaucoup de
femmes en intégrant des trimestres de
l'assurance vieillesse parent au foyer
dans l'éligibilité la pension minimum
comme dans lisibilité au dispositif de
carrière longue nous apportons une
première réponse en retenant et en
soutenant l'amendement présenté par
Philippe Vigier sur l'intégration des
indemnités journalières d'avant 2012
dans le calcul des retraites nous aidons
aussi au rétablissements et à
l'amélioration de la retraite des femmes
en faisant en sorte madame la députée
que la pension minimum telle que nous la
mettons en œuvre
la première c'est pour cela que nous
avons pour la première fois alors que
l'âge légal de départ est relevé nous
avons fait le choix de maintenir l'âge
de suppression de la décote à 67 ans
pour justement limiter cet effet qui
amène les femmes aller plus loin et puis
assumons ensemble nos responsabilités
surtout quand elles sont partagées
qu'est-ce qui fait une carrière hachée
qu'est-ce qui fait une carrière
incomplète c'est la durée de cotisation
en 2013 comme moi vous avez voté son
allongement je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
madame baptistel oui monsieur le
ministre je constate à ce stade c'est
que 11 milliards seront supportés par
les femmes et 7 par les hommes pour
atteindre les 18 milliards d'économies
la parole est à Monsieur Didier Lemaire
pour le groupe horizon
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires chers et chers collègues
en 2022 en France 700 communes ont été
concernées par des problèmes d'eau
potable dans le Haut-Rhin département
plutôt connu pour son climat tempéré
nous avions mis en place du citernage
nous sommes aujourd'hui le 7 mars et
plus de 6 départements sont d'ores et
déjà en vigilance ou alerte renforcée
concernant la sécheresse hivernale
la semaine dernière les premiers
incendies de forêts de 2023 ont eu lieu
cela nous rappelle l'été
particulièrement douloureux que nous
avons traversé en 2022 mais en annonçant
un prochain encore plus difficile à côté
de ça plusieurs aberrations ont toujours
lieu seul 1% des eaux usées sont
retraités en France nos 4135 piscines
publiques devront vidanger leurs
milliers de mètres cubes d'eau cette
année encore malgré des analyses
sanitaires saines il est toujours
interdit d'utiliser de l'eau de pluie
dans des sanitaires périscolaires et
piscine ou des EHPAD monsieur le
ministre je ne vous cache pas d'être
très inquiet j'ai appris au cours de ma
carrière de sapeurs-pompiers qu'en
matière de gestion de crise la chance
n'a pas sa place et que la prévention
reste son meilleur atout
dans ma circonscription une initiative a
été lancée en octobre dernier sur le
mois de l'eau il permet de sensibiliser
nos concitoyens et concitoyennes mais
aussi les élus agent communaux et
gestionnaires au rôle de l'eau monsieur
le ministre je vous demande pas de faire
tomber la pluie mais j'aimerais savoir
en attendant que des nuages gorgés d'eau
se pointe à l'horizon ce que vous
comptez faire face à ces nouveaux défis
et cela dès aujourd'hui je vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher que la parole
est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
le maire
on a vécu en été hors norme 700 commune
plus de 700 communes privées de vos
tables 1260 rivières qui se sont
trouvées en rupture d'écoulement et dès
la fin du mois de septembre
nous avons avec Agnès firmant le Baudou
avec Bérengère Couillard à Marseille
lancé les premières briques du chantier
de la planification écologique qui
aboutira dans quelques jours un plan de
plus d'une cinquantaine de mesures très
complet sur les aspects de qualité de
quantité de gouvernance pour faire en
sorte bien sûr de tenir compte de ce qui
s'est passé mais pas seulement
dans ce domaine avec évidemment un volet
outre-mer dans ce domaine sans attendre
dès le mois de septembre nous avons
également lancé une mission de retour
d'expérience confiée à quatre
inspections ministères de l'Agriculture
ministère de l'Intérieur ministère de la
Santé ministère de l'écologie pour faire
le point sur ce qui a marché sur ce qui
n'a pas marché remonté d'informations
suivies lien avec les collectivités etc
et puis dans la continuité dès le 23
février nous avons réuni le comité
d'anticipation sécheresse la semaine
dernière j'ai réuni l'ensemble des
préfets de bassin hier tous les préfets
de départements avec deux messages
simples le premier c'est de ne pas
hésiter dès maintenant à prendre des
mesures de restriction on y est à la
fois dans une situation inédite puisque
nous avons abordé cette année et en
particulier cette période de recharge
avec un niveau des nappes
particulièrement faible et nous avons
accusé un déficit pluviométrique depuis
le début de cette année et donc à date
on est dans une situation pire que
l'année dernière à la même époque c'est
la raison pour laquelle plus de 12
départements ont déjà des arrêtés de
vigilance ou d’alerte et ça ne va pas
s'arrêter puisque d'ici la fin du mois
de mars dans tous les départements les
comités ressources hauts vont se réunir
et à l'issue des décisions d'arrêter
seront prises on est donc pleinement
engagé là-dessus sur le front des
incendies il y a les mesures qui ont été
annoncées les 50 millions débloqués
d'ores et déjà pour les 10 la campagne
sur l'obligation légale de
débroussaillement et la location d'un
certain nombre d'agents aérien pour être
capable de faire face dès cet été merci
pour votre question ministre je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Ségolène
Amiot pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Ndiaye à votre avis quelle est
la profession déconsidérée et maltraitée
qui a connu à la fois un déclassement
salarial sans équivalent avec une perte
de 1% par an depuis 40 ans et une hausse
sans précédent du niveau de recrutement
du degré d'exigence professionnelle et
la diversité de ses missions
ce sont les enseignants et enseignantes
bien sûr
enseignants qui sont parmi les plus mal
payés de l'OCDE et dans les classes sont
les plus chargées d'Europe la profession
porte les stigmates de la brutalité du
ministère Blanquer et vous monsieur le
ministre vous avez été choisis pour
tenter de réparer les pots cassés
choisis pour ce que vous incarnez mais
sans que le moindre détail du décor
n'était échangé ce décor c'est celui
d'une logique néolibérale en marche
forcée depuis 2017 celui d'un ministère
des Finances qui dicte sa loi à tous les
autres
et c'est ainsi que vous décidez de
supprimer un millier de postes dans le
premier degré à la rentrée prochaine et
des centaines dans le second degré ainsi
que vous que vous vous asseyez sur la
promesse du candidat Macron de
revaloriser sans condition de 10% tous
les enseignants en janvier 2023
alors monsieur le ministre je vous le
demande comment allez-vous ramener les
syndicats autour de la table des
négociations si vous n'avez que des
fausses promesses et des polices privées
comme à Clichy-sous-Bois envoyé pour
casser du prof à leur offrir
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur papenzahi
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée à Miou le budget du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale augmente de 6 et
demi pour cent cette année c'est une
augmentation inédite voilà pour ce qui
concerne les chiffres globaux de ce
ministère qui vont permettre une hausse
de rémunération des enseignants
contrairement à ce que vous semblez
croire cette hausse de rémunération à
deux volets un volet inconditionnel pour
tous les enseignants dénéotitaires
jusqu'à ceux qui sont en fin de carrière
et puis en effet un volet assorti de
mission nouvelle facultatif pour celles
et ceux qui choisiront de s'engager dans
cette voie voilà pour ceux qui concerne
la hausse des rémunérations vous faites
allusion à une réunion technique qui a
été interrompue hier par les syndicats
ce qui est regrettable mais ce qui ne
remet pas en cause les négociations que
nous avons avec eux depuis le 18 janvier
50 heures de négociation jusqu'à présent
et elles vont se poursuivre nous avons
des différends sur les missions liées au
pacte mais cela fait partie de
l'ordinaire des échanges sincères que
nous avons avec les syndicats madame la
députée je vous demande de considérer
les faits les faits c'est d'abord une
baisse des effectifs scolaires que nous
ne compensons pas de manière
arithmétique bien au contraire puisque
le taux d'encadrement va s'améliorer
l'année prochaine c'est une augmentation
de rémunération des enseignants mais
aussi des personnels de direction mais
aussi des personnels administratifs
voilà la réalité voilà ce que nous
faisons madame la députée je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame
Amiot
monsieur le ministre vous n'entendez pas
ou plutôt vous n'écoutez pas ce que vous
demande légitimement les enseignants
l'égalité salariale entre les hommes et
les femmes la revalorisation salariale
ambitieuse et sans contrepartie de tous
les personnels les moyens nécessaires
pour instruire dignement nos enfants
monsieur le ministre actuellement vous
êtes en train de grossir les rangs des
manifestants de ce jour et de la semaine
avec les enseignants et les enseignants
qui sont légitimement en colère et qui
demandent aujourd'hui bien plus que le
retrait de cette réforme des retraites
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je pense que vous feriez mieux de vous
intéresser précisément et sérieusement
aux réformes entreprises pour
l'attractivité du métier de professeur
plutôt que d'inciter nos élèves sur un
réseau social douteux à bloquer les
établissements au mépris de la Loire je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Eric pouliard
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique Stanislas Guerini
en cette veille de 8 mars je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur la place des
femmes dans la fonction publique
premier employeur de France elle se doit
d'être exemplaire en matière d'égalité
professionnelle 62 % de ces agents étant
des femmes elles sont majoritairement
les visages de la République
mais malgré les statues les grades les
échelons qui définissent les grilles de
salaire dans la fonction publique les
inégalités demeurent
nous n'y avons pas encore atteint
l'égalité salariale ni la parité dans
l'accès au poste à responsabilité les
écarts de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes sont encore aujourd'hui de
12% beaucoup de choses ont été faites
pendant le précédent quinquennat la loi
de transformation de la fonction
publique du 6 août 2019 portée par le
ministre Olivier du socle et sur
laquelle je fus rapporteur pour avis
prévoit que les employeurs publics
mettent en place des plans d'action
pluriannuels relatifs à l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes ces plans permettent de
s'attaquer à plusieurs enjeux clés comme
les écarts de rémunération entre les
femmes et les hommes ou encore leur égal
accès au corps et emploi de la fonction
publique il contribue aussi à mieux
articuler les vies professionnelles et
personnelles et à mieux prévenir les
discriminations ainsi que les actes de
harcèlement moral ou sexuels votre
prédécesseur la ministre Amélie de
Montchalin ensuite créé le programme des
talentueuses afin d'accompagner les
femmes dans leur parcours professionnel
et les encourager à prendre des postes à
responsabilité nous le voyons l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans la
fonction publique est une question
essentielle sur laquelle des choses ont
été faites et d'autres restent à faire
monsieur le ministre vous êtes engagé
sur le sujet je le sais que comptez-vous
faire pour rendre exemplaire notre
fonction publique en matière d'égalité
professionnelle
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur c'est Stanislas Guérini
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député avec pouya
vous avez bien fait de rappeler tout ce
qui a été fait en matière d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans la
fonction publique mais je crois que on
pourra tous en convenir le chemin reste
long en matière d'égalité
professionnelle et avant de parler
d'égalité salariale je voudrais vous
parler des conditions de travail parce
que améliorer les conditions de travail
je crois que c'est la condition première
pour que tous les talents toutes les
compétences puissent s'exprimer et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons placé
notamment la santé des femmes et la
santé au travail avec la première
ministre au cœur de notre action pour
les mois et les années qui viennent on
nous attaquant à tous les sujets et
notamment au sujet qui était parfois
tabou dans notre société je dis cela en
pensant au 150 000 tous les ans qui
subissent des fausses couches la
situation actuelle c'est que quand une
femme subit une fausse couche que
légitimement son médecin lui prescrit un
arrêt de travail et bien en plus des
traumatismes parfois physiques parfois
psychologique elle subit une pénalité
financière parce que la situation
actuelle c'est qu'il y a aujourd'hui un
jour de carence dans la Fonction
publique sur les arrêts maladie liés au
fausse couche et bien monsieur le député
grâce à l'arbitrage immédiat d'Elizabeth
borne nous allons supprimer le jour de
carence Léo fausse couche dans la
fonction publique
et au-delà des conditions de travail
nous allons aussi aller plus loin en
matière d'égalité salariale je l'annonce
devant la représentation nationale nous
allons instaurer pour la fonction
publique l'index d'égalité salariale qui
existait dorénavant ou jusqu'à présent
pour le privé c'est index ça sera un
outil précieux pour pointer les
inégalités et surtout pour faire bouger
tous les employeurs publics de tous les
versants de la fonction publique
puisqu'il y aura des pénalités qui
pourront s'appliquer et de tout cela ne
pourrons parler pour tous ensemble d'ici
l'été modifier la loi je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Serge Müller pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Justice et
garde des sceaux Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti dans mon département la
Dordogne où il y a quelques années on ne
fermait ni les portes de nos maisons ni
celle de nos voitures
l'inquiétude s'installe et la population
se résigne en effet la délinquance se
structure elle s'organise et comme à
Marseille les dealers affichent les
tarifs sur les murs des immeubles nous
ne sommes qu'à Bergerac monsieur le
ministre nous ne sommes qu'à Bergerac
dans un département rural réputé calme
et pourtant il y a des rues du
centre-ville qui deviennent zone de
non-droit
nombreuses sur les jeunes femmes qui ne
sortent plus seuls allez leur dire que
l'insécurité n'est qu'un sentiment quand
les viols et les agressions sexuelles
ont augmenté de 30% en un an allez leur
dire que l'insécurité n'est qu'un
sentiment quand les coûts et blessures
volontaires ont augmenté de près de 400%
ces 20 dernières années
dans nos départements ruraux où les taux
de pauvreté atteignent les 20%. nous ne
pouvons laisser la délinquance organisé
et se structurer au risque qu'elle
devienne inévitables comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans nos métropoles
il nous faut des mesures fortes alors
monsieur le ministre je vous le demande
pourquoi êtes-vous opposé au
rétablissement des peines plancher
proposition de votre propre majorité
votre laxisme régalien laisse ses
développer l'insécurité qui je le répète
n'est pas qu'un sentiment
car certes monsieur le ministre si un
sentiment peut blesser je doute qu'il
puisse laisser des marques indélébiles
sur des visages je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux et
ministre de la Justice
les oreilles mentons lorsque je vous
entends monsieur le député Muller
d'abord d'abord je voudrais vous dire
que la proposition de loi
de nos amis d'horizons est une
proposition de loi nous avons débattu
ici longuement
l'Assemblée nationale a tranché il est
normal que les uns et les autres
puissent s'exprimer mais ces murs
voyez-vous ont des oreilles ils ont une
mémoire
retranscrites dans un compte-rendu je
voudrais vous dire que deux de vos
députés se sont particulièrement
illustrés le premier souhaitait des
peines plancher absolument obligatoire
et le juge ne pouvait pas si j'ose dire
s'en sortir il n'avait plus de liberté
juridictionnelle c'est totalement un
constitutionnel
deuxièmement l'une de vos députés nous a
dit que la luxe la justice était laxiste
c'est l'une de vos marottes raison du
fait qu'une cour d'assises avait
acquittée un certain nombre d'accusés
bon quand vous serez au pouvoir si cela
devait arriver vous condamnerez vos
condam vous condamnerez des hommes au
bénéfice au bénéfice du doute voilà
Monsieur voilà monsieur le député ne
cherchez pas à nous opposer à nos amis
d'horizons nous avons eu un débat serein
constructif nous avons argumenté vous
êtes comme d'habitude dans l'excès mais
avant de m'asseoir je voudrais vous dire
que des juridictions font à cet instant
l'objet de coupure de courant
cette origine est une origine
malveillante la justice doit sans doute
s'arrêter pour certains d'entre vous la
désobéissance civile c'est une
désobéissance à la loi je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Muller
vous avez fait vous aussi du blabla vous
n'avez pas répondu à ma question
la parole est à Madame Mathilde
Jonquières pour le groupe démocrates
la question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
le ministre le gouvernement a pris il y
a environ 15 jours un conseil des
ministres une ordonnance sur la prise en
charge des conséquences des désordres
causées par le phénomène naturel de
mouvement de terrain différentiel comme
le texte la rappeler plus de la moitié
des maisons individuelles en France sont
construites sur des sols argileux
susceptibles de présenter un risque
moyen ou fort de dégâts provoqué par un
phénomène naturel de succession
d'épisodes de sécheresse et de
ré-humidification des sols de plus sous
l'effet du réchauffement climatique nous
savons que la planète connaîtra
davantage d'épisodes de chaleur extrême
avec des épisodes de sécheresse plus
sévères et récurrents comme la
soulignait notamment la fédération
professionnelle France assureur qui
chiffre les sinistres à 43 milliards
d'euros entre 2020 et 2050 3 fois plus
que les 13,8 milliards indemnisés sur la
période de 1989 à 2019 pourtant si le
phénomène de retrait gonflement des sols
argileux est étudié et documentés en
France depuis plusieurs années il y a
encore une méconnaissance des et des
acteurs locaux sur l'impact de la
sécheresse et de ce phénomène sur le
bâti et les dispositions constructives
pour s'en prémunir les sinistrés se sont
ainsi souvent démunies face au coup des
travaux et à l'impact psychologique que
peut induire la dégradation de leurs
habitations face à ce constat ne
serait-il pas plus judicieux monsieur le
ministre de trouver des solutions
durables afin de prévenir au mieux ce
phénomène il y a aujourd'hui une
obligation d'études des sols mais qu'en
est-il de l'obligation de construction
pour mettre à l'abri les fructures
propriétaires que prévoit le
gouvernement à ce sujet ma deuxième
question concerne les victimes au-delà
de la compensation financière que
prévoit le gouvernement pour les
accompagner dans la transformation de
leur maison afin que celle-ci s'adapte
au mieux à ses mouvements de sol dû à la
sécheresse je vous remercie je vous
remercie ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
des Jonquères
j'associe Olivier Klein à la réponse que
je vais vous faire puisque c'est un
sujet que nous suivons avec le ministère
de la Ville et du logement vous l'avez
dit
plus de la moitié des maisons
individuelles de ce pays sont
construites sur des terrains argileux
qui sont susceptibles d'entraîner des
risques de retrait complément d'argile
avec un aller à moyen ou fort les
chiffres sont assez éloquents on était
sur une moyenne d'un demi milliard
d'euros d'indemnisation jusqu'à il y a
4-5 ans on est passé sur un milliard
d'euros par an en moyenne et le coût de
la sécheresse 2022 pourrait avoisiner
les 3 milliards d'euros uniquement sur
ce phénomène le gouvernement agit dans
deux directions une avec l'appui du
Parlement dans le cadre de la loi Elan
principalement pour les ventes de maison
de manière à mettre une obligation à la
charge du vendeur et pour les
constructions neuves avec l'obligation
d'une étude géotechnique de terrain qui
ensuite est communiqué au constructeur
et qui permet à priori de diminuer le
risque la prévalence ou la survenue de
choses de ce type
pour les constructions futures puisque
pour l'essentiel sur votre réconflement
d'argile est lié à des différencies de
terrain qui sont provoqués par la
sécheresse et à des constructions qui
sont pas adaptées reste le sujet de ceux
qui sont touchés et là c'est
l'ordonnance que nous avons présenté le
8 février dernier cette ardenance
d'abord elle facilite le fait d'être
indemnisé en disant c'est plus la
sécheresse d'une seule année qui compte
des sécheresses à répétition peuvent
entraîner une indemnisation et ensuite
on donne aux propriétaires un moyen de
se prémunir contre l'expertise
assurantielle pour être défendu de
manière à ce que l'assureur ne rechigne
pas à payer y compris pour les frais de
relogement quand les gens sont concernés
vous avez deux grands types de
dispositifs terrain neuf assurance reste
un nouveau volet
avec le réchauffement climatique avec le
dérèglement qui se poursuit et ce qu'on
doit pas penser à d'autres modes plus
pérenne qui ne reposent pas que sur le
régime des catastrophes naturelles ça
fera évidemment partie de l'objet des
réflexions qui ont été confiées au
service du ministère dans le cadre du
plan d'adaptation au changement
climatique dont nous conduisons la
révision
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
pour le groupe GDR merci madame la
Présidente
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre de l'économie avec
votre projet de recul brutal des
retraites l'envoler des prix
alimentaires et de l'énergie sont les
premiers sujets d'inquiétude des
Français avec 15% d'augmentation en
moyenne en un an c'est deux postes
occupa au sol un tiers des dépenses des
ménages les plus modestes cette
situation est intenable un chiffre
dramatique le prouve le recours à l'aide
alimentaire à tripler en disant mais
comme dans votre logiciel d'ultralibéral
périmé on imagine on exige jamais rien
des entreprises des multinationales pour
répondre à la crise de l'énergie vous
avez créé un bouclier tarifaire qui
s'est avéré ruineux pour les finances
publiques sans résoudre le problème pour
les Français et vous nous ressortez la
même routine pour la crise alimentaire
en demandant gentiment à la grande
distribution de faire un effort un
effort qui au passage va lui permettre
d'étouffer un peu plus les petits
commerçants les petits producteurs aux
riches les demandes polies et
inefficaces aux pauvre l'aide
alimentaire et les réformes injustes
pourtant une seule solution permettrait
de se sortir de l'ornière l'augmentation
des salaires des prestations et des
pensions depuis près de 15 ans les
politiques de modération salariale et
vos réformes qu'elle porte sur
l'assurance chômage ou sur les retraites
plombes le pouvoir d'achat de l'immense
majorité des Français beaucoup ne
peuvent plus vivre décemment des fruits
de leur travail
ils ne peuvent envisager de s'offrir des
produits locaux
issus de circuits courts ou simplement
partir en vacances il est donc temps
d'assumer vos choix politiques pourquoi
pourquoi refusez-vous d'indexer les
salaires du public et du privé sur
l'inflation pourquoi pourquoi
refusez-vous d'augmenter le SMIC les
prestations et les pensions en
conséquence
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
le respect que j'ai pour lui
l'amitié local donc évitons peut-être
les caricatures je partage totalement ce
que vous dites sur le choc
et à quel point il pénalise le
compatriotes en particulier les plus
modestes les deux postes les plus lourds
c'est effectivement l'énergie et
l'alimentation sur l'énergie aucun État
européen n'a fait autant que tout
nous avons mis en place un bouclier sur
l'électricité un bouclier sur le gaz les
factures audio augmenter de 180 à 200
euros dans certains pays européens c'est
300 350 euros ça n'est pas le cas pour
nos compatriotes français ça nous coûte
46 milliards d'euros et dans une logique
qui n'est pas très libérale vous le
reconnaîtrez bien volontiers nous sommes
allés prélever 26 milliards d'euros sur
les fournisseurs d'énergie donc nous
avons taxé lourdement les fournisseurs
d'énergie pour qu'il paye plus de la
moitié de ce bouclier énergétique
ensuite il y a l'alimentation là aussi
n'ont pas se pas rester des bras croisés
en disant les prix alimentaires
augmentent nous ne faisons rien nous
avons mis en place ce trimestre
anti-inflation il va coûter plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros au
distributeur et nous avons veillé vous
avez parfaitement raison de le souligner
à ce qu'on ne touche pas à la loi égalim
pour que les producteurs agricoles ne
soient pas pénalisés que ce soit pas eux
qui payent la facture au bout du compte
mais bien les distributeurs et je
souhaite que les grands industriels
payent aussi la facture ce qui nous
abonnés à demander à ce qu'on renégocie
les contrats fin juin à la fin de ce
trimestre anti-inflation pour que les
industriels les grands industriels
prennent aussi leur part de l'inflation
sur les salaires le SMIC je le rappelle
a augmenté de plus de 8 % depuis un an
parce que le SMIC le salaire minimum lui
il est indexé sur l'inflation et là où
j'ai peut-être une vraie différence avec
vous c'est que j'estime que indexer tous
les salaires sur l'inflation c'est
courir le risque d'entretenir
l'inflation là où nous notre objectif
premier c'est de faire disparaître
l'inflation elle devrait refluer mi-2023
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Nicolas Rey pour
le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé
21000 lits fermés depuis 2017 démission
de personnel services d'urgence saturés
sont les symptômes de la crise profonde
que traverse nos hôpitaux notamment dans
nos territoires ruraux et le
plafonnement de la rémunération des
médecins intérimaires qui va entrer
comme vous le savez en vigueur dans
quelques jours risque de déstabiliser un
peu plus nos hôpitaux en sous-effectif
ma question portera plus spécifiquement
sur le manque d'investissement dont
souffre nos hôpitaux en effet
l'investissement hospitalier a été
divisé par deux en 10 ans que ce soit à
Vienne à Pithiviers ou encore à Vichy
dans ma circonscription l'état des
bâtiments hospitaliers est indigne à
l'hôpital de Vichy un garde-corps et
même tombé du troisième étage du
bâtiment de pedopsychiatrique qui est en
état de délabrement mais ce qui est
choquant monsieur le ministre c'est que
de nombreux hôpitaux connaissent un
manque de soutien des ARS tout
simplement parce que leur situation
financière et jugées trop saine lors du
Ségur l'hôpital de Vichy n'a pas pu
bénéficier pleinement des aides à la
reprise de dettes uniquement parce qu'il
n'atteignait pas le taux d'endettement
requis et à ce jour le projet de
construction du nouveau bâtiment
principal et toujours en attente du
soutien financier de la RS visiblement
dans le système actuel on préfère
sanctionner les bons élèves monsieur le
ministre plus que de des plans à
répétition nos hôpitaux ont besoin
aujourd'hui d'une ressource budgétaire
pérenne et dédiée à l'investissement
comme l'a d'ailleurs recommandé la
commission d'enquête du Sénat alors ma
question sera simple comptez-vous enfin
insurer un financement stable suffisant
mais surtout équitable entre les
différents hôpitaux de nos territoires
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à François brode ministre de
la santé et de la prévention
monsieur le député Nicolas Rey vous le
savez je suis avec une grande attention
des situations de nos hôpitaux et j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour saluer
l'ensemble des soignants des hôpitaux
publics qui continuent à tenir bon la
ligne dans des situations par mois
difficiles alors je vais pas revenir sur
tous les éléments dont vous parlez les
fermetures de lys est un grand débat on
pourrait revenir avec des alternatives à
l'hospitalisation je veux juste un petit
point sur l'intérim vous semblez
brocarder un petit peu cette loi sur
l'intérim je vous rappelle simplement
qu'elle a été votée dans cette hémicycle
et donc je ne faisons que l'appliquer
certes un peu tardivement mais en tout
cas c'est sa mise en application
concernant l'investissement dans les
hôpitaux et je ne reviens pas sur la
reprise de dette dès 2019 qui a permis à
certains hôpitaux de remonter la pente
l'investissement du Ségur c'est quand
même 19 milliards d'euros en ce qui
concerne l'Allier dans la première vague
d'investissement c'est une somme de 55
millions d'euros nous avons pu en
discuter d'ailleurs récemment avec des
élus de l'Allier et le président maluré
ce n'est pas tous sa compagne d'un
changement à l'intérieur même des
hôpitaux avec un changement de
fonctionnement que je conduis à
l'intérieur des hôpitaux pour retrouver
l'échelle du service beaucoup plus
attractive pour l'ensemble des soignants
travailler sur l'organisation
territoriale et cela nous a pas échappé
revoir le financement des hôpitaux comme
l'a annoncé le président de la
République en début d'année pour sortir
du concept de toutes les deux ans en ce
qui concerne l'hôpital de Vichy je vous
confirme que nous comptons l'accompagner
de manière très significative toujours
dans le cadre de ce Ségur
d'investissement le budget est en train
d'être structuré séquencé avec les élus
autour de 130 à 140 millions d'euros sur
une période de 5 à 10 ans ce budget fait
suite à un projet médical pour voter par
l'ensemble de la sécurité de la
communauté pardon médical et bien
entendu l'État sera présent aux côtés de
l'établissement pour conduire cette
rénovation du site de Vichy
monsieur le ministre monsieur Rey oui le
président de la République a fait de
nombreuses annonces lors de ses vœux au
monde de la santé monsieur le ministre
vous attendons des actes concrets des
engagements précis il en va de la
dignité de nos soignants et de la santé
des Français je vous remercie la séance
de questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]